have you ever wondered how google maps
autocorrect and chatbots work
dissolve due to ai and deep learning
artificial intelligence is changing
business at a rapid rate ai and deep
learning are also impacting our lives
outside the office self-driving cars
smart assistants like amazon alexa and
disease mapping are a few examples of ai
that are impacting our personal lives
each and every day
companies like tesla and uber use ai and
machine learning to develop reliable
transportation solution for everyone
everywhere ai and deep learning are
lurking in the background every time you
open your facebook newsfeed do a google
search recommendation from netflix or
book a hotel online on tribal artificial
intelligence has become in industry in
recent years ai is a branch of computer
science that deals with building
intelligent machines capable of
performing complex tasks and taking
decisions by mimicking the human brain
deep learning on the other hand is a
subset of machine learning that is used
to build and train artificial neural
network he in deep learning refers to a
neural coach at facebook and professor
at new york university
says deep learning combined with
reasoning and planning is one area of
research making promising advances right
now ai and deep learning together can
solve repetitive problems data bring
more efficiently into our lives we
encounter new problems developed by
integrating ai into our lives with this
understanding of ai and deep learning
let's go ahead and learn them in detail
[Music]
artificial intelligence and deep
learning are two vastly growing
technologies today and have created a
revolution in the business sector hi
everyone welcome to this video tutorial
an ai and deep expert in artificial
intelligence and deep learning
our highly experienced instructors will
teach you everything from scratch but
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first we will learn the basics of
artificial intelligence with a short
animated video
then we will look at the future of ai
and understand ai in depth with hands-on
demonstrations in python
we will learn the top 10 artificial
intelligence technologies in 2021 and
shift our focus to understanding deep
learning in detail you will learn the
basics of deep learning followed by
neural networks
moving further you will get an idea
about the two most popular deep learning
frameworks tensorflow and keras
you will also get an idea about
recurrent neural network and generative
adversarial networks finally we will
understand computer vision using the
opencv library and look at the top deep
learning interview questions so let's
get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in art
onto a field in spite of a variation in
lighting landscape and dimensions of the
field the ai robot must perform as
expected this ability to react
appropriately to a new situation is
called generalized learning the robot is
now at a crossroad one that is paved and
the other rocky the robot must determine
which path to take based on the
circumstances this portrays the robot's
reasoning ability after a short stroll
the robot now encounters a stream that
it cannot swim across using the plank
provided as an input the robot is able
to cross this stream so our robot uses
the given input and finds the solution
for a problem this is problem solving
these three capabilities make the robot
artificially intelligent in short ai
provides machines with the capability to
adapt reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
in the ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai you might
say alexa is definitely not a weak ai
since it can perform multiple tasks
well that's not really true when you ask
alexa to play despacito it picks up the
keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa can not provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technic
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain
this means through deep learning data
and
patterns can be better perceived
ray kurzweil the well futurist predicts
that by year 2045 we would have robots
as smart as humans
this is called the point singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b
a robot with the muscular skeletal
system
see
a ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short
[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai as we have been
to specifically target tasks that we
need or want done in place of ourselves
that's how ai will ultimately unfold
it is a renaissance it is a golden age
we are now solving problems with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanities has ever worked on and i
think of it as something more profound
than electricity or fire and anytime you
work with technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits while minimizing the downside
[Music]
[Applause]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and uh clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars there are
others
and we sort of see it as the mother of
all ai projects
there's a class of things like game
plane
or speech recognition or image
recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know mind blowing
certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery
these biological systems are very
complicated and so the fact that we have
you know vaccines for tb and hiv coming
that's partly enabled by this rich data
advance in biology and machine learning
when i look at
seeing ai which is an application we
just launched for anybody with visual
impairment they can go download this app
that uses the latest cutting edge
computer vision technology in our cloud
to give anyone the ability to see and in
fact angela mills was a colleague of
mine was just telling me about how it's
changed her life inside of microsoft she
can go into our cafeteria order food
using this app with confidence walk into
conference rooms with confidence because
she knows she's walking into the right
conference room or what we've done with
our onenote and word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use ai
to be able to read better the latest
release of windows 10 has this
capability called eye gaze which is
something that we learned working with
steve gleason and the als patients
saying if you all you have is the eye
muscle
and the gaze can we help you type
yeah you have to be careful
uh when there's advances in a sense
we're all better off if machines can
make all the food and the clothes and
none of us have to work
uh and you think okay now we have all
the freedom if we want to stand behind
the
counter and you know
make sandwiches okay you can if you want
but there's this other way to make those
goods and services but it will be very
disruptive uh because you know say your
mid-career in manufacturing or driving
then it's a disruption now we've had
that in a slow way for hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers
you have to worry about it otherwise
you're not going to solve it right and
it's important to understand tomorrow
whether google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress
uh you know technology has
this nature it's going to evolve
i think
pulling back history shows pulling back
countries which pull back don't do well
with the change we know that
20 30 years ago you educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that so we have to
transform how we do education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done you
know on the back of you know technology
or you know is going to be fundamentally
vulnerable yeah so i think
uh technology in particular ai can in
fact bring more empowerment more
inclusiveness and at the same time we
should be clear-eyed about displacement
clear-eyed about unintended consequences
like any other technology and work both
skilling so that you know people can
find the jobs of the future create new
jobs and
lastly i think have a set of policy
decisions
that really help people
as they go through this change
the risks are uh important and i think
the way we solve it is
we think ahead we worry about it
we
do things like from from be upfront uh
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one be very
transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there and figure out
global frameworks by which we can engage
just like paris agreement and climate
change you know using forums like this i
think we bring people together to engage
on the hard questions and i think ansys
will emerge
um you know i have exposure to the very
most cutting edge
ai
and i think people should be really
concerned about it
um i keep sounding the lawn belt but
you know until
people see like robots going down the
street killing people like they don't
know how to react you know because it
seems so ethereal
and
i think we should be really concerned
about ai and i think we should
this is the ai's rare case where i think
we need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive
because i think by the time we're
reactive in ai regulation it's too late
right now we have
machine learning algorithms that can
solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially complete idiots and
like two-year-olds and anything that's
not that problem they're dumb they're
like that you can give them this
enormous data set and they come up with
brilliant correlations and insights but
they're not going to plug in the skynet
and you know like like like threaten us
anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic
and uh i don't think
artificial intelligence is a threat i
don't think that if artificial
intelligence is something terrible
but human beings are smart enough to
learn that
[Music]
what is artificial intelligence and
today's world is probably one of the
most exciting advancements that we're in
the middle of experiencing as humans so
what is artificial intelligence and here
we have a robot with nice little clampy
hands hey what am i you are what we call
artificial intelligence i am your
creator reminding him who programmed him
and who he's supposed to take care of
artificial intelligence is a branch of
computer science dedicated to creating
intelligent machines that work and react
like humans in today's place where we're
at with artificial intelligence i really
want to highlight the fact that they
work and react like humans because that
is where the development of artificial
intelligence is and that's what we're
comparing it to is how it looks like
next to a human thanks any tasks you
want me to do for you get me a cup of
coffee poof here you go he brings him a
cup of coffee that's my kind of robot i
love my coffee in the morning you'll see
there's kind of a side theme of coffee
today's uh tutorial so here we have a
robot that's able to bring him a cup of
coffee seems pretty far out there you
know that we have a walking robot that's
doing this but it's not as far out there
as you think we have automatic coffee
pots we have devices that can move an
object from one point to the other you
know anything from amazon delivering
packages or whatever you want all these
things are in today's world we're right
on the edge of all this that's what
makes this so exciting such an exciting
topic and a place of study so let's take
a look a real general look at types of
artificial intelligence in the really
big picture i mean we drill into it
there's like machine learning and all
kinds of different aspects but it's a
generic level of artificial intelligence
so hi there discovered four different
types come have a look so we have our
kind of einstein looking guy or
professor at some college so the very
first part that we're really this is as
reactive machines they've been around a
long time this kind of ai are purely
reactive and do not hold the ability to
form memories or use past experiences to
make decisions these machines are
designed to do specific jobs remember i
talked about the programmable coffee
maker that makes coffee in the morning
it doesn't remember yesterday from
tomorrow it runs its program even going
back to our washing machines they have
automatic load balancers that have been
around for decades so reactive machines
we program to do certain tasks and they
have no memory but they're very
functional then we have limited memory
this is kind of right where we're at
right now this kind of ai uses past
experience and the present data to make
a decision self-driving cars are kind of
limited memory ai we bring up
self-driving cars because that's a big
thing especially in today's market they
have all these images that they brought
in and videos of what's gone on before
and they use that to teach the automatic
car what to do so it's based on a
limited memory limited memory means it's
not evolving new ideas they have to
actually uh when they need to make a
change they have the programming built
on the memory but then they have to make
those changes outside of that and then
put the new setup in there so it's
continually reprogramming itself theory
of mind these ai machines can socialize
and understand human emotions machines
with such abilities are yet to be
developed of course that's under debate
there's a lot of places that are working
on the theory of mind and having it be
able to cognitively understand somebody
based on the environment their
facial fears all kinds of things and
evolve with them so their own they have
some kind of reflective ability to
evolve with that and finally
self-awareness this is the future of ai
these machines will be conscious so
they'll be able to react very much like
a human being although they'll have
their own flavor i'm going to achieve
artificial intelligence well the main
arena right now is machine learning
machine learning provides artificial
intelligence with the ability to learn
this is achieved by using algorithms to
discover patterns and generate insights
from the data they are exposed to and
here we have a computer as we get more
and more to the human realm of art and
official intelligence you see this guy's
listening to he's inside his hidden
networks and machine learning programs
deep learning which is a subcategory of
machine learning keeping provides
artificial intelligence the ability to
mimic a human brain's neural network it
can make sense of patterns noise and
sources of confusion in the data let's
try to segregate different kinds of
photos using deep learning so first we
have our pile of photographs much more
organized in my boxes in my closet of
photographs the machine goes through the
features of every photo to distinguish
them this is called feature extraction
bingo figures out the different features
in the photos and so based on those
different features labels of photos it
says these are landscapes these are
portraits these are others so it
separates them in there if you've ever
been on google photos a favorite of mine
i go through there and i type in dog and
i get all the images of my dog it's
pretty amazing how it's able to pull
those features out so when we're
achieving artificial intelligence and
the deep learning let's take a closer
look and see just how deep learning
works there are a lot of models out
there this is the most basic model used
this is a neural network there are three
main layers in a neural network the
photos that we want to segregate go into
the input layer and so we have a picture
of mona lisa it looks like and a couple
of people when it goes into the first
input layer the arrows are drawn to like
individual dots each one of those white
dots in the yellow layer or in the input
layer would be a pixel in the picture
maybe a value for that pixel so the
picture of the mountains goes in there
and it fills in that whole input layer
and then the next error the nightscape
goes in there hidden layers responsible
for all mathematical computations or
feature extraction on our inputs so when
you see here we have the two kind of
orangish red layers here and there's all
these lines in there those lines are the
weights each one of those represents a
usually a float number or a decimal
number and then multiplied it by the
value in the input layer and you'll see
that as it adds all these up in the
hidden layer each one of those dots in
the hidden layer then has a value based
on the sum of the weights and then it
takes those and puts it into another
hidden layer and you might ask well why
do we have multiple hidden layers well
the hidden layers function as different
alternatives to some degree so the more
hidden layers you have the more complex
the data that goes in and what can they
can produce coming out the accuracy of
the predicted output generally depends
on the number of hidden layers we have
so there we go the accuracy is based on
how many hidden layers we have again it
has to do with how complex the data is
going in the output layer gives us the
segregated photos so once it adds up all
these weights and you'll see there's
weights also going into the output layer
based on those weights it'll say yes
it's a portrait no it's a portrait yes
it's a landscape no it's a landscape and
that's how we get our setup in there so
now we were able to label our photos
take a look and see what that looks like
in another domain we have photograph
domain now let's look at it in the
airline ticket so let's predict the
airline ticket prices using machine
learning these are the factors based on
which we're going to make predictions
and choosing your factors is so
important but for right here we'll just
go ahead and take a look what we got we
have airlines we have the origin airport
the destination airport departure date
here are some historical data of ticket
prices to train machine so we pull in
the old data this is what's happened
over the years now that our sheen is
saved let's give it new data for which
it'll predict the prices if remember our
four different kinds of machines we have
machines with memory well this is the
memory part it remembers all the old
data and then it compares what you put
in to produce the new data to predict
the new prices the price is one thousand
that's an expensive flight of course
if that is a us dollars if it's india i
don't know what the price range is on
that hopefully it's a good deal for
wherever you're going so we predict the
prices and this is kind of nice because
if you're looking way ahead it'd be nice
to know if you're planning a trip for
next year
how much those tickets are going to cost
and they certainly fluctuate a lot so
let's take a look at the applications of
artificial intelligence we're going to
dive just a little deeper because we
talked about photos we've talked about
airline ticket prices kind of very
specific you get one specific number but
let's look at some more things that are
probably more in-home more common right
now speaking of in-home this young
gentleman is entering his room of course
makes a comment like we all do we walk
into a room this room is dark isn't it
let's see what happens when i enter it
the sensors in my room detect my
presence and switch on the lights this
is an example of non-memory machines
okay you know it senses you it doesn't
have a memory whether you've gone in or
not some of the new models start running
a prediction as to whether you're in the
room or not when you show up when you
don't so they turn things on before you
come down the stairs in the morning
especially if you're trying to save
energy you might have one of those fancy
uh thermostats which starts guessing
when you get up in the morning so it
doesn't start the heater until it knows
you're going to get up so here he comes
in here and this is one of the examples
of uh smart machine and uh that is one
of the many applications of artificial
intelligence one of the things we're
developing here in our homes okay bye
abruptly he leaves leaving his nice
steaming cup of coffee there on the
table and when he leaves the sensors
detect he's gone and turn off the lights
let's watch some tv did someone say tv
the sound sensors on the tv detect my
voice and turn on the tv sounds kind of
strange but with the google dongle and a
google home mini you can actually do
just that you can ask it to play a movie
downstairs on your downstairs tv true
also with the amazon fire stick and all
the different artificial intelligent
home appliances that are coming out
pretty amazing time to be alive and in
this industry here you have one more
application of artificial intelligence
and you can probably think of dozens of
others that are right now on the cutting
edge of development so let's jump into
my favorite part which is a use case
predict if a person has diabetes and in
the medical domain i mean if you read
any of these they say predictive a
person has diabetes but in the medical
domain we would want to restate this as
what is the risk is a person a high risk
of diabetes should just be something on
their radar to be looking out for and
we'll be helping you out with the use
case there we are with a cup of coffee
again i forgot to shave as you can see
we'll start with the problem statement
the problem statement is to predict if a
person has diabetes
and we might instruction statement but
if you were actually using this in a
real case again you would say your high
risk of diabetes would be the proper way
to present that to somebody if you ran
their test data through here but that's
very domain specific which is outside of
the problem statement as far as the
computer programmers involved so we have
a look at the features these are the
things that have been recorded and they
already have this data from the
hospitals one of them would be number of
times pregnant obviously if you're a guy
that'd be zero glucose concentration so
these are people who've had their
glucose measured blood pressure age age
is a big factor an easy thing to look at
insulin level so if someone's on insulin
they probably have diabetes otherwise
they wouldn't be taking insulin but that
would affect everything else and we add
that in there if they're if they're
using insulin let's start off with the
code so we're going to start off by
importing parts of our data set and if
we're going to do this let's jump into
one of our favorite tools we're going to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook so let
me flip over there and we'll talk just
briefly about that and then we'll look
over this code so here we are in the
jupyter notebook and
this is an inline editor which is just
really cool for messing with python on
the fly you can do demos in it it's very
visual you can add pieces of code it has
cells so you can run each cell
individually you can delete them but you
can tell the cell to be a comment so
that instead of running it it just skips
over it there's all kinds of cool things
you can do with jupiter notebook we're
not going to go into that we're actually
going to go with the tensorflow and you
do have to import all the different
modules in your python now if you're in
a different python ide that's fine it'll
work in just about any of your python
ides and i'll point out the one
difference in code when we get to that
which is the inline for doing our graph
and in this code we're going to go
through we're going to load our data up
we're going to explore it we're going to
label it and then we'll use the
tensorflow and then we'll get down to
the end where we're going to take a look
at how good the model is does it work so
let's start with the top part here and
let me go ahead and let's paste that
code in there i've added a line in at
the top i've added the folder because i
didn't put it in the same folder as the
program that's running you don't need to
worry too much about that but if you
have a folder issue or says file doesn't
exist you probably have it in the wrong
folder or you need to add the folder
path and then we're going to import
pandas and let me just one of the cool
things since it's in internet chrome we
can just do that control plus and zoom
right in there and we have the import
pandas as pd so go ahead and draw a line
of there you can see that the pandas as
pd add a little drawing thing in there
to make it easier to see pandas is a
data set it's a really nice package you
can add into your python usually it's
done as pandas as pd that's very common
to see the pd here let's circle that
it's basically like an excel spreadsheet
it adds columns it adds headers it adds
a lot of functionality to look at your
data and the first thing we're going to
do with that is we're going to come down
here and we're going to read and this is
a csv it's a csv file you can open up
the file on your computer if you want if
you need access to the file you can
either search it and download it from
the main thing or type a note in down
below on the youtube video and simply
learn will help you get that file also
and that's true of any questions you
have on this you can add comments down
there and somebody at simplylearn
actually keeps an eye on that and we'll
try to answer those questions for you i
put in the full path you don't have to
if you have your data files saved in the
same folder you're running your program
in and this is just a csv file comma
separated variables and with the pandas
we can read it in there and we're going
to give it put it right in a variable
called diabetes and then finally we take
diabetes and you'll see diabetes.head
this is a pandas command and it's really
nice because it just displays the data
for us let me go ahead and erase that
and so we go up to the run button up
here in our jupyter notebook which runs
the script in this that's a cell we're
in and you can see with thediabetes.head
since it's a pandas data frame it prints
everything out nice and neat for us and
this is really great and if i go ahead
and do a control minus i can get it all
to fit on the same screen and this is
the first five lines when you do the
head of the data just prints out the
first five lines in programming of
course we start with zero so we have
zero one two three and four there we go
we have yeah here we go we start with
zero we have zero one two three and four
we have our titles going across the top
and of course the first column is number
of pregnancies glucose concentration for
the second one blood pressure
measurements of triceps as we keep going
you'll see you can guess what most of
these things are group i'm not sure this
is probably the test group i didn't look
it up to see specifically what that is
anytime you start exploring data and for
this example we don't really need to get
too much in detail you want to know the
domain what does this information mean
are we duplicating information going in
that's beyond the scope of this for
right now though we're just going to
look at this data and we're going to
take apart the different pieces of this
data so let's jump in there and take a
look at what the next set of code is so
in our next setup or our next step we
gotta start looking at cleaning the data
we gotta start looking at these
different columns and how are we gonna
bring them in which columns are what i'm
gonna jump ahead a little bit and also
as we look at the columns we're gonna do
our import our tensorflow as tf that's a
common import that's our tensorflow
model tensorflow was developed by google
and then they put it into open source so
that it's free for everybody to use
which is always a nice thing so let's
take a look at what these two steps look
like in our jupiter notebook so let's
paste this code in here and this is
something that happens when you're
messing with data is you'll repeat
yourself numerous times we already have
diabetes head so i'm going to put the
little pound sign which tells python
that this is just going to be a comment
we're not going to run it a second time
in here we have diabetes dot columns and
then diabetes columns to norm equals
diabetes columns to norm.apply lambda x
let's talk about that but let me first
run that and let's see what that comes
out with that and then
let's put the next set of code in also
and i'm going to run that let me just
hit the run button it doesn't really
have an output but we did a lot of stuff
here so let's go over what we did on
this so i've turned on my drawing
implement
to help go through all this there's a
lot going on here the first thing is we
have all of our columns up here of our
column names let me just highlight that
and draw a circle around that like we
did earlier and we want to look at just
specific columns and we're going to
start let me change the color on this so
it really sticks out i'll use like a
blue i'm going to look at these columns
and we're not going to do age class or
group we're going to look at those in a
different way and i'll explain in a
little bit what that's about so we're
looking at number of pregnancies
basically anything that can be read as a
float number and you might say age could
be read as a float number we're going to
address that differently because when
you're doing statistics we usually take
the ages and we group them into buckets
and we'll talk about that and so we're
going to take these columns and we're
going to do what they call normalize
them call them to normalize what is
normalize if you're using the sk learn
module one of their neural networks they
call it scaling or scalar this is in all
of these neural networks what happens is
if i have two pieces of data and let's
say one of them is in this case 0 to 6
and one of them is in
insulin level is 0 to maybe 0.2 would be
a very high level i don't know what they
actually go to a neural network will
look at this six and it'll go zero to
six and as you get into zero six here's
an eight even a higher number it will
weight those heavier and so it'll skew
the results based more on the number of
pregnancies than based on the insulin or
based on the blood pressure so we want
to level the playing field we want these
values to all be in the same area we do
that by normalizing it here and we use a
lambda function this is always a kind of
a fun thing we take the diabetes it's a
panda set up and let me just erase all
that so we can go down here put it back
to red and we take our diabetes which is
a panda data set and we only want to
look at the columns to normalize because
that's what we built we built a list of
those columns and we're going to apply
a lambda function and you'll see lambda
all kinds of python programming it needs
a function we put x in and whatever is
outside of the x over here it then takes
that and returns that value so
the new value is going to be whatever x
is minus x min again it's a pandas data
set so we can get by with that which is
really cool makes it easy to read so we
take x we look for the minimum value of
x and then we divide that by the maximum
value x minus the x min or the width and
what this essentially does is if you're
going from 0
to 15 it's going to divide by 15 and
then we subtract it let's make this two
instead of zero or 20 uh 20 to 115 there
we go first off we set this to zero so
we subtract x min so right off the bat
the minimal value is going to be zero
and then we divide it by the difference
here x min minus x max or x max minus x
min this basically sets all the values
between 0 to 1. and that's very
important if we want to make sure that
it's not going to be a skew in the
results if it's not going to weight the
values one direction or the other zero
to one that's what this is doing and
again there's like so many different
ways to scale our data this is the most
basic scale it's standard scaling and
it's the most common and we spelled it
out in the lambda you can there's actual
um modules that do that but lambda is
just it's such an easy thing to do and
you can see really see what we're doing
here so now we've taken these columns
we've scaled them all and changed them
to a zero to one value we now need to
let the program know the tensorflow
model that we're going to create we need
to let it know what these things are so
to do that i create a variable called
number pregnancy keep it simple and
we've imported the tensorflow as tf one
line of code brings our tensorflow in
for us awesome love python so you get
number of pregnancies and tf.feature
column.numeric column we're going to
tell it's a numeric column so it knows
that this is a float value zero to one
and then number underscore pregnant so
we're taking that column and we've
reshaped that column from zero to one
and no that doesn't mean you have a
point one pregnancy it just means zero
point one equals one or something number
pregnant so we're just mapping this data
so tensorflow knows what to do with it
and we go through all of these we go
through
all the way up to again we're not doing
age let me just separate age down here
these have all been adjusted age we're
going to handle differently we still put
it as a numerical column because it is
so let me just circle age and group we
didn't even touch group yet we're going
to look at group and age and we're going
to do some special stuff with that class
we're going to look at last why because
this is whether they have diabetes or
not that's what we're testing for so
this is our history we know these people
have diabetes or not and we want to find
out we want to create a model and then
we want to test that model predicting
whether somebody new has diabetes or not
so here i am still with my cup of coffee
working away refill number three let's
explore both the categorical group which
is going to be the a b c and d on the
end and also the age we're going to talk
about those a little bit more and then
we're going to combine all those
features and we'll jump into splitting
the data although that's kind of the
next step but we'll put that all
together what are we doing with the age
and what are we doing with the group
down there so let's flip on over and
take a look at our
jupiter notebook so the first thing is
let's put this new set of code in here
and run it and let's talk about what
we're doing on this set of code in i
actually want to go one more step
forward on the next set of code or part
of it there we go and i can go and just
run that while we have it that's fine
let's just scroll up a little bit here
and let's go through what we just did
with this set of code if we go back up
here
to the top part we have group b c b b c
we learned from the header so when i
come down here we're going to create a
signed group and let me get my drawing
pad out so we're looking at this first
one up here assigned group tf feature
column categorical column with
vocabulary list that is a mouthful this
is saying that this is a categorical
list in this case we have a b c d you
see this a lot in tensorflow a lot of
times tensorflow is used to analyze text
or logs error logs and they're just full
of all this information and they take
these in this case a b c d but in other
cases it'd be words and they create
numbers out of them so it has zero this
is one column this is another column
this is another column this is another
column and it's just this way of being
able to look at this in a different
light and assigning them different
values you really don't want to assign
this a float value first thought might
be let's assign this 0 to 3 0 1 2 3 for
a b c d but if you did that it would try
to add 1 plus 2 to get 3 as part of its
math and functions and that just isn't
true c does not equal a plus b
c is just a categorical name it could
have been the frank group and laura's
group in a bids group but it's not you
know these are they're not float numbers
so very important you have that
distinction in your data the next step
we're looking at is our map plot and
we're going to do this this is a cool
useful tool we're going to import
matplot library dot pi plot as plt
standard import and this next line here
is really important we're doing the
matplot library we want it to be inline
that's because we're in a jupiter
notebook remember i told you before that
if you're running this in a different
ide you might get a different result
this is the line you need if you want to
see the graph on this page and then we
do diabetes we're going to look at just
the age and dot hist bins equals 20.
what the heck is that well it turns out
that because this is remember it's a
pandas there's our pd pandas as pd
because this is a pandas panda
automatically knows to look for the
matplot library and a hist just means
it's going to be a histogram and we're
going to separate it into 20 bins and
that's what this graph is here so when i
take the diabetes and i do a histogram
of it it produces this really nice graph
we can see that at 22 most of the
participants in this probably around 174
of the people that were
recorded were of this age bracket
they're right here in this this first
column here and as they get further and
further down they have less and less and
less until when you're at 80 you can
actually see down here there's almost
none in a couple of these categories and
this is important to know because when
you're doing census you know the older
the the group is the more the people
have passed away so you're going to have
this in any of your senses as you take
you're always going to have a much
larger group in the younger crowd and
then it gets lower and lower as they get
older and i mentioned the word buckets
here we go we're going to create an age
bucket we're going to put people in
buckets can you imagine people sitting
in buckets kind of a funny way of
looking at it this just makes it easier
for us to separate it when i go to the
doctor's office i don't want to be told
well your age 22 this is you know you'll
get a decent one at 22.
here we are back to my cup of coffee i
told you coffee was an underlying theme
these next couple steps are very
specific to tensorflow up until now we
had some tensorflow as we set the
categories up but you'd have to set that
up with any model you use to make sure
they're set correctly they'd be set up a
little differently but we run input
functions and in tensorflow this allows
for some really cool things to happen
and this is why tensorflow is so
predominant in a lot of areas so let's
take a look at these next couple lines
of code here we're going to create the
input function and we're going to go
ahead and create the model and let me go
ahead and put these codes in here i went
ahead and split it up so it's different
lines so we can talk a little bit about
that and then the actual model and let
me go ahead and run this so we can see
what that looks like and in my
particular environment it just prints
out a little bit of information about
the model not too worried about looking
at that but we do want to take a closer
look at what we did here so we've
created an input function and again this
is very specific to tensorflow with the
input function we have our train we have
our x equals x train and our y equals y
train because we want to train it with a
particular information but we have these
other settings in here these two
settings and the number of epics is how
many times it's going to go over our
training model epic means large that
means all the data so we're going to go
over it a thousand times that's actually
a huge overkill for this amount of data
usually it only needs probably about 200
but you know when we're putting it
together and you're trying things out
you just kind of throw the numbers in
there and then you go back and fine-tune
it sometimes the batch size is really
important this is where tensorflow does
some really cool things if you're
processing this over a huge amount of
data and you try to batch everything at
once you end up with a problem this
means we're only going to read 10 lines
at a time through our data so each one
of those rows of testing they've done
we're only going to look at 10 of them
at a time and put that through our model
and train it and then shuffle
self-explanatory we're just moving we're
just randomly selecting which data and
what order we go in that way if there's
like you know five in a row that are
kind of weighted one way and vice versa
it mixes them up and then finally we
create our model so the model goes in
there and goes okay i have a tf dot
estimator dot linear classifier we're
going to put in the feature columns
equals feature columns we defined all
our columns up above and then we have in
classes equal two and that just means we
have our out result is zero or one you
have diabetes or you don't have diabetes
or in this case we actually call it high
risk of diabetes and then i put one more
line of code in there which i forgot
we've set up our model we set up our
feature columns now we need to actually
train it
model.train you'll see this so common in
so many different neural network models
this is like a standard what's different
though is we have to feed it the
function remember we created this
function with all this information on it
and then we have steps in uh steps
similar to number of batches and batch
size it's more like a individual lines
we step through a thousand is a lot more
common for steps than epics but steps is
used you probably leave this out in this
particular example and let's go ahead
and run this all together because it has
a site when we start training it we get
a different output so here we go i've
run it it's given me the information
from when i created the model and now it
just starts going through we get this
information tensor loss equals global
step all kinds of stuff going on here
and if you're following this it's just
going through the steps and training it
it gives you information you could dig
deep into here but for this particular
setup we're not going to go too deep on
what's going on just know that we've
trained our model this model now has the
information we need in it to start
running predictions so as we sip our
next um take our next step of coffee or
maybe it's tea or if you're one of those
strange late night workers maybe it's a
sip of wine we go into the next step we
actually want to run some predictions on
here but we don't want to run the
training we want to run the test on
there we want to take our test data and
see what it did and so that's what we're
going to do next is we're going to run
the test through and actually get some
answers so if you were actually
deploying it you would pull the answers
out of the data it's bringing back let's
take a look at that in our jupyter
notebook so here we go let's paste it in
there i'm going to go ahead and run it
and you'll see that as it goes it's
actually putting the answers out if you
remember correctly well we'll walk
through this here in just a second but
it goes through and it runs each line
and it gives you a prediction for each
line one at a time and prints them out
so let's take a look and see what that
actually looks like let's start with
this first part we've created another
function this is just like the other
function except for
x equals x test and there's no y why is
there no y because we don't know what
the answer is on this yet we don't want
to tell it the answer we wanted to guess
what the answer is so we can evaluate
that and see how good it did on that 33
of the data so this is our x test batch
size is 10 again so if we were watching
this roll down here we would see that it
actually processes it 10 lines at a time
it's only going to go through once it
goes through all the x test data one
time we don't need to have it predict
multiple times and shuffle equals false
very important we set the shuffle to
false because if we were tracking this
and actually giving people answers we'd
want to make sure it connects to the
right person so they get the right
results of course we're just doing this
to evaluate it so let's take a look down
here with a put out and as i scroll down
to my jupyter notebook we have some
information as far as a tensorflow
running and then the actual output and
if we look at the output we know by this
first bracket in python it's an array we
know um by this squiggly bracket that
this is a dictionary so that this is a
label the dictionary has logistic
probabilities class ids classes and so
this whole first part let me redo that
this whole first part is one
output and we know that because there is
the bracket there and there is this
bracket here for the dictionary and it's
a dictionary of terms so if i pulled
this out i looked at object 0 in here i
would go down to let me just find it
here it is classes remember how we
define classes we define classes as our
answer and so it's guessing our
tensorflow says based on all the
information you gave me i'm guessing
this first entry of our first test data
is high risk diabetes uh oh go get
tested change your diet watch what
you're eating you know high risk one and
if we go down far enough we can see down
here is another one where classes equal
zero i skipped a couple because they're
all ones up here the b
this particular output b
in front of the one means it's a binary
output it only comes out as zero or one
and there's a lot of other information
in here you can dig deep into tensorflow
and
explain these different numbers that's
way beyond the scope of what we're
working on today so the basics of it
though is you get an output we have an
output of whether the person has
diabetes or not well in this case it's
high risk of diabetes or not so now that
we've run our predictions take a sip of
coffee a short break and we say well
what do we need to do well we need to
know how good was our predictions we
need to evaluate our model so if you're
going to publish this to a company or
something like that they want to know
how good you did let's take a look at
what that looks like in the code so
let's paste that in here and
just real quick go back over this by now
this function should look very uh this
is we're going to call it eval input
function it should be pretty
straightforward here we have our tf
estimator inputs pandas input function
and then we have our x test our y test
so this time we want to give it the
answer so it has something to uh see how
good it did on batch is 10 processing 10
at a time we're only going once through
the data we're not shuffling it although
it doesn't really matter with this and
then we're going to do results equals
model dot evaluate and we put our
evaluation function in there this should
all look familiar because we're
repeating the same thing it's very
similar with a couple different changes
as far as what we're feeding it and the
fact that we're doing an evaluation
let's see what that looks like when we
run it and we go up here to our run
model you'll see warnings on some of
these because i didn't install this on
its own install so a lot of it is this
temporary files because i'm using the
jupiter notebook instead of setting it
up on a regular machine and we get our
output and we'll go ahead and just look
at this output real quick and then we'll
flip over and from here you'll see that
it generates an accuracy a baseline
average loss the mean gives you a
precision prediction it gives you all
kinds of information on here so let's
flip over and see what's important and
we'll look at the slide here we are in
this slide and this should be exciting
because we just about wrapped up our
whole tensor flow and tensorflow is one
of the more complicated models out there
so give yourself a pat on the back for
getting all the way through this when we
look at this output we have an accuracy
of 0.7165
that's really what we want to look at
that means that we have an accuracy if
you're just truncating it of 71 percent
that's quite good for our model you know
given a small amount of data we came up
with a 71 percent of letting people know
they're high risk or not with diabetes
so we created a model that can predict
if a person has diabetes based on some
previous records of people who were
diagnosed with diabetes and we've
managed to have an accuracy of 71
which is quite good the model was
implemented on python using tensorflow
again pat yourself on the back because
tensorflow is one of the more
complicated scripts out there but it's
also one of the more diverse and useful
ones i am keef tana and today we shall
be talking about the top 10 artificial
intelligence technologies
so
without further ado let's quickly jump
into the topic
in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices virtual agents
speech recognition
augmented reality
machine learning
robotic process automation
decision management deep learning and
finally image recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are a tvo
automated insights sas cambridge
semantics digital reasoning narrative
science
etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smart phones
smart speakers etc
virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective
but digital impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment
place an order and can even avail
product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant and amazon
alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are microsoft google amazon and
assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another sub
discipline of artificial intelligence
which is used to convert human speech
into a comprehensive and useful format
for computer applications to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used in interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are nuanced
communications open text
nice and variant systems
augmented reality
yet another trendy technology in the
field of artificial intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of the real physical world that is
achieved using sound digital visual
elements and other sensory stimuli
delivered wire technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment
it alters the perception of the real
world environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and furnishing much more fun
and interactive
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
machine learning
machine learning is an application and
an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machines
being able to learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis
big data and applications and training
tools enterprises are heavily investing
in machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction
some of the sample vendors are amazon
fractal analytics
google
microsoft etc robotic process automation
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
fields like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are pika systems
automation anywhere blue prism
etc next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
insurance sector
e-commerce and many more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica advanced systems
concepts pika systems
mana
etc
deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct fluid ai
math works saffron technology
etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces detect license plates and
diagnose diseases the present day image
recognition is compatible to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users clarify guggums and senstine
provide this technology
what do you think is making our lives
easier off late and how do you think the
world is rapidly changing imagine
getting into a car feeding your
destination as the input and
automatically getting dropped off at
your destination at the same time you
sit back and relax through the ride
without having to do anything at all
physically whoa
life has become so much simpler with all
kinds of automation taking us through
everyday life what do you think is
making all this possible artificial
intelligence thanks to numerous
advancements in technology which is
bringing about a lot of changes in our
day-to-day lives to drive innovation ai
is using machine learning taking things
one step further so what exactly do you
mean by artificial intelligence
in simple terms ai refers to simulating
a machine with human intelligence and
programming the device to think and act
like humans artificial intelligence also
called machine intelligence is far
beyond roboz as portrayed by science
fiction from google search algorithm to
amazon's alexa to apple siri to
self-driven cars ai progresses rapidly
towards a harmonious future between
technology and man bringing together the
best of both worlds
since the machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence and perform tasks as we do
it's termed as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956.
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry solving algebra
word problems and much more between the
1950s and 1970s neural networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world now
is the era of deep learning the boons of
ai undoubtedly ai has changed our lives
in many ways at number one we have
safety factor there are many fields like
defense mining etc where human health is
at significant risk ai is the biggest
moon in these fields where a robo or a
drone does the work instead of a human
with the invention of self-driven cars
ai is airing at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition ai helps in effective
communication by processing and
understanding the language spoken by
humans it is also capable of
comprehending the words spoken by humans
and reciprocate in the same way all this
is possible by the voice assistant
feature which the ai bots have at number
three we have daily needs
be it alexa or apple siri we are
surrounded by various applications that
run on ai fingerprint detection face
detection gps grammarly all these run on
artificial intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket buying a
product online and driving a car ai has
limited human interaction and provides
various services
in all the unexpected ways ai is helping
humans in the day-to-day needs
at number four we have healthcare ai is
a promising tool for supporting
healthcare administration it helps
healthcare workers and stakeholders to
manage vast amounts of data and
transform them into potentially
life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the
corvid 19 coronavirus a who report
released said that ai is a vital part of
the response to this disease ai systems
are being developed predicting people's
temperatures and survival rates with
more than 90 accuracy one promising
approach of ai in the field of health
care is it guides vaccine design as
covet 19 began to spread globally
machine learning tools were used to
search immunogenic components of the
virus that would make good vaccine
candidates yet another field where the
ml is significantly evolving is genomics
which is the study of the complete set
of genes within an organism ai can
sequence and analyze dna much faster
cheaper and accurate than the
researchers ever will at number 5 we
have robus one of the most amazing
inventions by humans that thinks
intelligently and acts autonomously the
disinfecting robots are playing a
significant role in these uncertain
times they rove around healthcare
facilities spreading uv light to
disinfect places contaminated with
viruses
the benefits of ai robust far exceed the
apprehensions
speaking of role of technology
advancements
artificial intelligence is rapidly
advancing with a lot of computers and
robots capable of doing miracles
though the machines and robots cannot
have human feelings they can think and
act like humans companies use techniques
like machine learning and neural
networks to accomplish artificial
intelligence which is also called
machine intelligence in the present
scenario considering the total
intelligence we can conclude that 95 of
it is machine intelligence and the
remaining 5 is what we call human
knowledge speaking of ai versus human ai
has a positive as well as a negative
impact on us and society according to
some recent studies seven million
existing jobs will be replaced by ai in
the uk between 2017 and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created as well
a study from mckinsey global institute
states that by 2030 automation will
replace 400 to 800 million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cost fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries
the biggest challenge is how people
would make a living with these changes
and uncertainty
google ceo sundar pichai has claimed
that ai will be more transformative to
humanity than electricity ever will
google even launched an ai system which
bet some of the best atari 2600 game
players
also did you know that the bestest
player in the world is a machine how
would it be when the best doctor in the
world is a machine the best teacher is a
machine the best architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots ais and
robos will replace fast food joints and
radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
your robo will perform your surgery it
won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field
warning by musk
this is extremely important um
i think the danger of ai is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by a lot
um
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and
mark my words
ai is far more dangerous than nukes
or
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight
this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways not everyone is ready to
welcome ai with open arms some ai
experts like stephen hawking and elon
musk have warned us about the looming
dangers that ai minko says to humanity
they have even suggested that ai is
likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species
elon musk says that he is close to the
cutting edge in ai which scares him a
lot ai is vastly more than almost anyone
knows and the rate of improvement is
exponential he also says that ai is far
more dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat ai can be
harmful to us in two different ways the
idea that ai will become conscious and
responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes
if the super-intelligent ai more
intelligent than us becomes conscious we
will look at humans like how humans will
look at monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey where
one of the most well-known ais turned
terrible the terminator the matrix and
few others these movies have speculated
about ai that far exceeds the
expectations of its creators and escapes
their control eventually targeting
humans for extinction
speaking of the real reasons to be
afraid of ai
there are doctors engineers accountants
judges architects who seek information
from an ei system they treat this
information as it is from a trusted
colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong ai researchers pride
themselves on the accuracy of results it
is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake these systems do not
fail gracefully one such incident is
when facebook had to shut down a
controversial chatbot experiment where
the two ais developed their own language
for communication a research was
conducted with two chatbots named alice
and bob focusing on how to negotiate
with each other unfortunately the
researchers found that the bots had
deviated from the actual script and had
started inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left unsupervised they developed
their machine language which was
otherwise developed to converse with
people that's the scary part of ai
neural networks and deep learning the
developers and researchers working on
this would have no idea what it's doing
this technology can get complicated and
we have to make sure what we are doing
with it holds value we must also handle
it cautiously because ai is a direct
reflection of us people should lead and
not follow so here's the question should
we be afraid of ai
we all know that ai is a transformative
technology that we have ever seen in the
history of humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power it
has the potential to be transformative
both for good reasons as well as for the
wrong however fear of the unknown has
always been the case with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what ais
ai is defined by the algorithms that
dictate its behavior and operate under
definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness what if an
ai machine starts to have human feelings
and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas also we don't
think that is anywhere in our near
future pretty much any type of machine
can be used for either good or bad
reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop or pause
in a death talk peter house says imagine
you're driving up a mountain and it's
raining very heavily as you climb into
the mountains the rain is turning into
snow and pretty soon that snow is a
white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you you start skidding you
see some vehicle was coming to crash
into you all this wouldn't have happened
if you paused your journey as the rain
was getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now
that rain will turn into snow soon and
that snow could quickly become a
dangerous blizzard
so we need to pause check the conditions
put in place safety standards and ask
ourselves how far we want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people in
the loop
spot checking what the ai algorithms are
doing keeping people in the loop will
probably solve some of our most
significant challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier however evolved these ar
machines are they still lack human
empathy and consciousness
so instead of running away from this
technology we should understand this
revolutionary technology and make sure
it is used in the right way to make our
lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning you can check
out simplylearn's postgraduate program
in ai and machine learning in
partnership with purdue university ever
wondered how google translates an entire
web page to a different language in a
matter of seconds or your phone gallery
groups images based on their location
all of this is a product of deep
learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior machine learning is a technique
to achieve ai through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done machine learning we'd
have to tell the machine the features
based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit 9 on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits each number
is present as an image of 28 times 28
pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels each of these has a value
attached to it and hence is called a
weighted channel all neurons have a
unique number associated with it called
bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neural which is
then applied to a function known as the
activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues up till the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training a neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function leave your
answers in the comments section below
some of the popular deep learning
frameworks include tensorflow pytorch
keras deep learning 4j cafe and
microsoft cognitive toolkit considering
the future predictions for deep learning
and ai we seem to have only scratched
the surface in fact horus technology is
working on a device for the blind that
uses deep learning with computer vision
to describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises and that is
deep learning for you in short
there are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the heart as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
and at the end we will end up with a
small demo code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we use what is
known as machine learning and within
machine learning a subset of machine
learning is deep learning machine
learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so a little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use structured data in deep
learning the data would be primarily
images or voice or maybe text files so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on
the weights and biases we will see what
exactly weights in biases are as we move
the input gets processed and that
results in an output in a biological
neuron the output is sent through a
synapse and in an artificial neuron
there is an equivalent of that in the
form of an output and biological neurons
are also interconnected so there are
billions of neurons which are
interconnected in the same way
artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that's some w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information this is the
process of supervised learning so the
output is already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized
this iteratively the weights and biases
keep changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero the error may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mcculloch and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and
nor using neurons and that was a
significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a output
is a b in case of an or gate it is a
plus b and so on and so forth and they
were able to do this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we'll see
why that is in a little bit so this is
how an and gate works the inputs a and b
the output should be fired or the neuron
should be fired only when both the
inputs are one so if you have zero zero
the output should be zero for zero one
it is again zero one zero again zero and
one one the output should be
one so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this logic so for example if we
have equal weights like 0.7 0.7 and then
if we take the sum of the weighted
products so for example 0.7 into 0 and
then 0.7 into 0 will give you 0 and so
on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are 1 you get a
value which is greater than 1 which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is one so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an or gate in order to
implement an or gate in case of an or
gate the output will be one if either of
these inputs is one so for example zero
one will result in one or other in all
the cases it is one except for zero zero
so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example one
point two now if you see here if in the
first case when both are zero the output
is zero in the second case when it is
zero and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0 and then 1.2
into 1 is 1. and in the second case
similarly the output is 1.2 in the last
case when both the inputs are 1 the
output is 2.4 so during the training
process these weights will keep changing
and then at one point where the weights
are equal to w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2
is equal to 1.2 the system learns that
it gives the correct output so that is
implementation of or gate using a single
neuron or a single layer perceptron now
xor gate this was one of the challenging
ones they tried to implement an xor gate
with a single level perceptron but it
was not possible and therefore in order
to implement an xr so this was like a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realized that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3 and h4 and then you
take the output of that and feed it to
the output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the input is 0
1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if
you now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as one if
we use a sigmoid with the threshold one
you will see that in these two cases it
is zero and in the last two cases it is
one so this is the implementation of xor
in case of xor only when one of the
inputs is one you will get an output so
that is what we are seeing here if we
have either both the inputs are one or
both the inputs are zero then the output
should be zero so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
one and then only you will get an output
of one which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent
neural network deep neural network and
deep belief network so and each of these
types of neural networks have a special
you know they can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has
some special characteristics and they
can they're good at performing certain
special kind of tasks what are some of
the applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks a special type
called generative adversarial networks
which can be used for synthesizing
either images or music or text and so on
and they can be used to compose music so
the neural network can be trained to
compose a certain kind of music and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with google google's self-driving car
and today a lot of automotive companies
are investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road
the lane markings on the road
signals
any objects that are in front any
obstruction and so on and so forth so
all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it can be breast cancer and
so on and so forth so health care is a
major area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of 784 pixels so all the
information what is inside this image
can be kind of compressed into this 784
pixels the way each of these pixels is
lit up provides information about what
exactly is the image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify
the images so let's take a look how this
works so each neuron the value if it is
close to 1 that means it is white
whereas if it is close to zero that
means it is black now this is a an
animation of how this whole thing works
so these pixels one of the ways of doing
it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer take the 784
pixels as input the values of each of
these pixels and then you get an output
which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say circle or
it will say it's a triangle so as a part
of the training process
we then send that error back and the
weights and the biases of these neurons
are adjusted till it correctly
identifies that this is a square that is
the whole training mechanism that
happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is
trained to identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at same way a
triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
edges into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be
observed is that when you feed a new
image it is not necessary that
the image or the the triangle is exactly
in this position now the neural network
actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
verify that it is a triangle and that is
the whole idea behind pattern
recognition so how does this training
process work this is a quick view of how
the training process works so we have
seen that a neuron consists of inputs it
receives inputs and then there is a
weighted sum which is
nothing but this x i w a summation of
that plus the bias
and this is then fed to the activation
function and that in turn gives us a
output now during the training process
initially obviously when you feed these
images when you send maybe a square it
will identify it as a triangle and when
you maybe feed a triangle it will
identify as a square and so on so that
error information is fed back and
initially these weights can be random
maybe all of them have zero values and
then it will slowly keep changing so the
as a part of the training process the
values of these weights w1 w 2 up to wn
keep changing in such a way that towards
the end of the training process it
should be able to identify these images
correctly so till then those are
adjusted and that is known as the
training process so and these weights
are numeric values it could be 0.5 0.25
0.35 and so on it could be positive or
it could be negative and the value that
is coming here is the pixel value as we
have seen it can be anything between 0
to 1 you can scale it between 1 or 0 to
256 whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the buyer is also
a numerical value we need to keep in
mind that the bias is fixed for a neuron
it doesn't change with the inputs
whereas the weights are one per input so
that is one important point to be noted
so the bias also keeps changing
initially it will again have a random
value but as a part of the training
process the weights the values of the
weights w1 w2 wn
and the value of b
will change
and ultimately once the training process
is complete these values are fixed for
this particular neuron w 1 w 2 up to w n
and plus the value of the b is also
fixed for this particular neuron and in
this way there will be multiple neurons
and each there may be multiple levels of
neurons here and that's the way the
training process works so this is
another example of multi-layer so there
are two hidden layers in between and
then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the training
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model and
those values will be fixed once the
training is completed all right then
there is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be 0
or 1 is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum you remember we talked
about w i x i plus b that weighted sum
is fed as an input to the activation
function and then the output can be
either a zero or a one and there are
different types of activation functions
which are covered in an earlier video
you might want to watch all right so as
a part of the training process we feed
the inputs the label data or the
training data and then it gives an
output which is the predicted output by
the network which we indicate as y hat
and then there is a labeled data because
we for supervised learning we already
know what should be the output so that
is the actual output and in the initial
process before the training is complete
obviously there will be error so that is
measured by what is known as a cost
function so the difference between a
predicted output and the actual output
is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using the differentiation
and so on and so forth but the idea is
this so as a training process as a part
of training the whole idea is to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function
the cost function at certain
levels it is very high the cost value of
the cost function the output of the cost
function is very high so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent you need to specify
what should be the learning rate and the
learning rate should be optimal because
if you have a very high learning rate
then the optimization will not converge
because at some point it will cross over
to the side on the other hand if you
have very low learning rate then it
might take forever to convert so you
need to come up with the optimum value
of the learning rate and once that is
done using the gradient descent
optimization the error function is
reduced and that's like the end of the
training process all right so this is
another view of gradient descent so this
is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached a minimum value and
it will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradient descent and then this is
another example so you can have these
multiple local minima so as you can see
at this point when it is coming down it
may appear like this is a minimum value
but then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient is
an algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensorflow and so
that's the reason we have uh this
tutorial we've created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using python and tensorflow is an
open source platform created by google
so let's just take a look at the details
of tensorflow and so this is a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for
developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so usually you have a one
dimensional array so first of all you
can have what is known as a scalar which
means a number and then you have a one
dimensional array something like this
which means this is like a set of
numbers so that is a one dimension array
then you can have a two dimensional
array which is like a matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional
arrays that is the strength of
tensorflow and which makes computation
deep learning computation much faster
and that's the reason why tensorflow is
used for developing deep learning
applications so tensorflow is a deep
learning tool and this is the way it
works so the data basically flows in the
form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually execute that
particular graph in the form of what is
known as a session you will see this in
the tensorflow code as we move forward
so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional
vector in which case the rank is
supposed to be one and then you can have
a two dimensional vector typically like
a matrix then in that case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a three
dimensional array then rank is 3 and so
on so it can have more than 3 as well so
it is possible that you can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run on
cpus as well as gpus gpu is a graphical
processing unit just like cpus central
processing unit now in earlier days gpu
was used for primarily for graphics and
that's how the name has come and
one of the reasons is that it cannot
perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform
iterative actions or computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is uh just a suggestion
but if you're already familiar with how
tensorflow works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hello world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
mnist database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with mnist
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
mnist also offers a bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that's used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted away that it is very easy
to handle so that is mnis database and
the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for simplicity
what we will do is we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are 784 pixels so pixel number one
starts here it goes all the way up to 28
then 29 starts here and goes up to 56
and so on and the pixel number 784 is
here so we take all these pixels flatten
them out and feed them like one single
line into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a softmax layer what it does is
once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and if you feed a number 9 like
this
then
this particular neuron gets activated so
you get an output from this neuron let
me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine
let's say this has been trained and now
if you're feeding a number 9 this will
get
activated now let's say you fade 1 to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed 2 this neuron will
get activated and so on i hope you get
the idea so this is one type of a neural
network or an activation function known
as soft max layer so that's what we will
be using here this is one of the simpler
ones for
quick and easy understanding
so this is how the code would look we
will go into our lab environment in the
cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the languages python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this tf is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of tf and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and mnist database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
8 okay
so in this case all the remaining values
there will be a bunch of zeros so this
is like array at position 0 this is at
position 1 position 2 and so on and so
forth let's say this is position 7 then
this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be 0 okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a two here let's say then
the labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as zero the zeroth position
the first position is also zero the
second position is one because this
indicates number two and then you have
third as zero and so on okay so that is
the significance of this one hot true
all right and then we can
check how the data is uh looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5000 so all together there are
70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplot clip library and this
is how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is one because
this is a scaled value so one means it
is white and
0 means it is black and in between is it
can be anywhere in between black and
white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and
each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a a matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784
matrix because there are 10 neurons and
similarly there are biases now remember
i mentioned bias is only one per neuron
so it is not one per input unlike the
weights so therefore there are only 10
biases because there are only 10 neurons
in this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x
with w right this is what we were doing
x w plus b you're just adding b and this
is in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf.nn
softmax cross entropy with logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define
what should be the learning rate how
fast you need to come down that is the
learning rate and this again needs to be
tested and tried and to find out the
optimum level of this learning rate it
shouldn't be very high in which case it
will not converge or shouldn't be very
low because it will in that case it will
take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick start the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we wanted to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so
let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will log in
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and uh so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walkthrough
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5 000. now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is uh black so that's why
you will mostly see zero say either it
is black or white but then there are
these values are so the values are
actually they are scaled so their values
are between 0 and 1 okay so this is what
you're seeing so certain locations there
are some values and then other locations
there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show
and then if you pass this parameters
appropriately you will be able to see
the different images now i can change
the values in this position so which
image we are looking at right so we can
say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
five as eight
what is in fifty
again eight so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how i'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10
actual values okay so
one for
this 10 is for each neuron there are 10
units and 784 is for the pixel values
inputs that are given which is 28 into
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had x as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of
10 digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so the up to here remember what
we have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole structure and
format of this code will be completely
different from how we normally do
programming so even with people with
programming experience may find this a
little difficult to understand it and it
needs quite a bit of practice so you may
want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done uh maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this but even in spark the
the programming the code itself is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happens slightly
differently but in tensorflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
rather not but setting up the variables
and
the graph that's all defining
maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have
created the variables how to load the
data loaded the data viewed the data and
prepared everything but you have not yet
executed anything in tensorflow now the
next step is the execution intensive law
so the first step for
doing any execution intensive flow is to
initialize the variable so any time you
have any variables find in your code you
have to run this piece of code always so
you need to basically create what is
known as a node for initializing so this
is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf dot session
will give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a
width
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf.session as says you say says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are doing that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init so we say run that particular node
and that is when the initialization of
the variables happens now what this does
is if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w is a variable and b is a variable
so any variables that we created you
have to run this code you have to run
the initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this with block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for 1000
steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for 1000 iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of performing deep
learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next patch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of hundred images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then get the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set
right so this is what we are trying to
do here the code may appear a little
complicated because if you're seeing
this for the first time you need to
understand
the various methods of tensorflow and so
on but it is basically comparing the
output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is uh calculated as well so
this is the accuracy and that is what we
are trying to see how accurate the model
is in predicting these numbers or these
digits okay so let us run this this
entire thing is in one cell so we will
have to just run it in one shot it may
take a little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is pretty good
for such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90 percent accuracy
however in real life this is probably
not sufficient so there are other ways
in to increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent let's look at the
different types of artificial neural
networks and this is like the biggest
area growing is how these all come
together let's see the different types
of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them used this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six to keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output be used for future prediction
recurrent neural networks so the hidden
layers remember its output from last
time and that becomes part of its new
input you might use that especially in
robotics or flying a drone you want to
know what your last change was and how
fast it was going to help predict what
your next change you need to make is to
get to where the drone wants to go
applications text-to-speech conversation
model so i talked about drones but you
know just identifying on lexis or google
assistant or any of these they're
starting to add in i'd like to play a
song on my pandora and i'd like it to be
at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so that
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case i use
facial images or google picture images
as one of the options modular neural
network it has a collection of different
neural networks working together to get
the output so wow we just went through
all these different types of neural
networks and the final one is to put
multiple neural networks together i
mentioned that a little bit when we
separated people in a larger photo in
individuals in the photo and then do the
facial recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a cutting
edge you hear the term pipeline and
there's actual in python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just cutting edge and
it's so experimental i mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain then
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feed forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenon
self-organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
it brings them all together and no the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
the dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python
3.6 it's always nice to tell people the
version of python because that does
affect sometimes which modules you load
and everything and we're going to start
by importing the required packages i
told you we're going to do this in cross
so we're going to import from karas
models sequential from the cross layers
version 2d or conv 2d max pooling 2d
latin and dents and we'll talk about
what each one of these do in just a
second but before we do that let's talk
a little bit about the environment we're
going to work in and in fact let me go
ahead and open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about carrass so
here we are on the cross website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s dot io that's the
official website for cross and the first
thing you'll notice is that cross runs
on top of either tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or theano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit they talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we're
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big i can add in an r
relu layer and then i can add in a
softmax layer the next instance we
didn't talk about softmax so you could
do each layer separate now if i'm
working in some of the other kits i use
i take that and i have one setup and
then i feed the output into the next one
this one i can just add hidden layer
after hidden layer with the different
information in it which makes it very
powerful and very fast to spin up and
try different setups and see how they
work with the data you're working on and
we'll dig a little bit deeper in here
and a lot of this is very much the same
so when we get to that part i'll point
that out to you also now just a quick
side note i'm using anaconda with python
in it and i went ahead and created my
own package and i called it the cross
python 3 6 because i'm in python36
anaconda is cool that way you can create
different environments real easily if
you're doing a lot of different
experimenting with these different
packages probably want to create your
own environment in there and the first
thing is you can see right here there's
a lot of dependencies a lot of these you
should recognize by now if you've done
any of these videos if not kudos for you
for jumping in today pip install numpy
scipy the scikit-learn pillow and h5py
are both needed for the tensorflow and
then putting the cross on there and then
you'll see here and pip is just a
standard installer that you use with
python you'll see here that we did pip
install tensorflow sensor we're going to
do cross on top of tensorflow and then
pip install and i went ahead and used
the github so git plus git and you'll
see here github.com this is one of their
releases one of the most current release
on there that goes on top of tensorflow
and you can look up these instructions
pretty much anywhere this is for doing
it on anaconda certainly you'd want to
install these if you're doing it in
ubuntu server setup you'd want to get i
don't think you need the h5py and ubuntu
but you do need the rest in there
because there are dependencies in there
and it's pretty straightforward and
that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can say i have
python 30.5 and python36 i used to have
a bunch of other ones but it kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my
in this case i'm using google chrome and
in here i can go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
browser window when you use the anaconda
do you have to use anaconda and jupyter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential that's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you'll notice i'm always sipping coffee
i always have a in my case latte next to
me and espresso so the next step is to
go ahead and initialize we're going to
call it the cnn or classifier neural
network and the reason we call it a
classifier is because it's going to
classify it between two things it's
going to be cat or dog so when you're
doing classification you're picking
specific objects you're specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so their sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and the next step is to add
in our convolution and let me just do a
let me shrink that down in size you can
see the whole line and let's talk a
little bit about what's going on here i
have my classifier and i add something
what am i adding well i'm adding my
first layer this first layer we're
adding in is probably the one that takes
the most work to make sure you have it
set correct and the reason i say that
this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 4 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
picture is coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's the value coming out based
on the weights and the value going in
and
from there you know it's
if it's over one then it's good or over
zero it's good if it's under zero then
it's considered not active and then we
have this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to two
dimensional kind of setup so it's very
aware that this is a photograph and that
different pieces are next to each other
and then we're going to add in a second
convolutional layer that's what the co
inv stands for 2d so these are hidden
layers so we have our input layer and
our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two dimensions by we actually
have 64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes kara so
nice is i can with just a couple flips
of code put in a whole new layer that
does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by keras i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128. they
got that you just say where did they get
128 from you could actually play with
that number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 as 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple of
whatever the data shape you're already
using is in and we're using the
activation the relu just like we did
before and then we finally filter all
that into a single output and it has how
many units one why because we want to
know whether true or false it's either a
dog or a cat you could say one is dog
zero is cat or maybe you're a cat lover
and it's one is cat and zero is dog if
you love both dogs and cats you're gonna
have to choose and then we use the
sigmoid activation if you remember from
before we had the relu and there's also
the sigmoid the sigmoid just makes it
clear it's yes or no we don't wanna any
kind of in-between number coming out and
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see it's still all in setup and then
finally we want to go ahead and compile
and let's put the compiling our
classifier neural network and we're
going to use the optimizer atom and i
hinted at this just a little bit before
where does adam come in where does an
optimizer come in well the optimizer is
the reverse propagation when we're
training it it goes all the way through
and says error and then how does it
readjust those weights there are a
number of them atom is the most commonly
used and it works best on large data
most people stick with the atom because
when they're testing on smaller data see
if their model is going to go through
and get all their errors out before they
run it on larger data sets they're going
to run it on atom anyway so they just
leave it on atom most commonly used but
there are some other ones out there you
should be aware of that that you might
try them if you're stuck in a bind or
you might blur that in the future but
usually atom is just fine on there and
then you have two more settings you have
loss and metrics we're not going to dig
too much into loss or metrics these are
things you really have to explore cross
because there are so many choices this
is how it computes the error there's so
many different ways to on your back
propagation and your training so we're
using the atom model but you can compute
the error by standard deviation standard
deviation squared they use binary cross
entropy i'd have to look that up to even
know what that is there's so many of
these a lot of times you just start with
the ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
what these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the karass website to explore them
deeper but we're going to go ahead and
run them and now we've set up our
classifier so we have an object
classifier and if you go back up here
you'll see that we've added in step one
we added in our layer for the input we
added a layer that comes in there and
uses the relu for activation and then it
pulls the data so this is even though
these are two layers the actual neural
network layer is up here and then it
uses this to pull the data into a two by
two so into two dimensional array from a
three dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our outer
flattened and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128 and we use the relu again
and then finally we reduce that down to
just a single output and we use the
sigmoid to do that to figure out whether
it's yes no true false in this case cat
or dog and then finally once we put all
these layers together we compile them
that's what we've done here and we've
compiled them as far as how it trains to
use these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it where you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neuron that
network to the images
from cross and let me just zoom in there
i always love that about working with
jupiter notebooks you can really see
we're going to come in here we do the
cross pre-processing and image import
image data generator so nice of course
it's such a high-end product right now
going out and since images are so common
they already have all this stuff to help
us process the data which is great and
so we come in here we do train data gen
and we're going to create our object for
helping us train it for reaping data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with the photos
or different shapes and sizes like i
said it's a wonderful package you really
need to dig in deep to see all the
different options you have for setting
up your images for right now though
we're going to stick with some basic
stuff here and let me go ahead and run
this code and again it doesn't really do
anything because we're still setting up
the pre-processing let's take a look at
this next set of code and this one is
just huge we're creating the training
set so the training set is going to go
in here and it's going to use our train
data gen we just created dot flow from
directory it's going to access in this
case the path data set training set
that's a folder so it's going to pull
all the images out of that folder now
i'm actually running this in the folder
that the data sets in so if you're doing
the same setup and you load your data in
there and you're doing this make sure
wherever your jupyter notebook is saving
things to that you create this path or
you can do the complete path if you too
you know c colon slash etc and the
target size the batch size and class
mode is binary so the class is we're
switching everything to a binary value
batch size what the heck is batch size
well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 of the images as tests and
eighty percent to train it and then
finally we've set up all our data we've
set up all the layers which is where all
the work is is cleaning up that data and
making sure it's going in there
correctly and we're actually going to
fit it we're going to train our data set
and let's see what that looks like and
here we go let's put the information in
here and let's just take a quick look at
what we're looking at with our fit
generator we have our classifier dot fit
generator that's our back propagation so
the information goes through forward
with a picture and it says oh you're
either right or you're wrong and then
the air goes backward and reprograms all
those weights so we're training our
neural network and of course we're using
the training set remember we created the
training set up here and then we're
going steps per epic so it's 8 000 steps
epic means that that's how many times we
go through all the pictures so we're
going to rerun each of the pictures and
we're going to go through the whole data
set 25 times but we're going to look at
each picture during each epic 8 000
times so we're really programming the
heck out of this and going back over it
and then they have validation data
equals test set so we have our training
set and then we're gonna have our test
set to validate it so we're gonna do
this all in one shot and we're gonna
look at that and they're gonna do 200
steps for each validation and we'll see
what that looks like in just a minute
let's go ahead and run our training here
and we're going to fit our data and as
it goes it says epic one of 25 you start
realizing that this is going to take a
while on my older computer it takes
about 45 minutes i have a dual processor
and we're processing uh 10 000 photos
that's not a small amount of photographs
to process so if you're on your laptop
in which i am it's going to take a while
so let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i changed these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here well we have 8
000 pictures we're going through so for
each epic i'm going to change this to
four thousand cut that in half so it's
going to randomly pick 4 000 pictures
each time it goes through an epic and
the epic is how many processes so this
is 25 and i'm just going to cut that to
10. so instead of doing 25 runs through
8 000 photos each which you can do the
math of 25 times 8 000. i'm only going
to do 10 through 4 000. so i'm going to
run this 40 000 times through the
processes and this thing i noted you'll
you'll want to notice is that i also
changed the validation step and this
would cause some major problems in
releasing because i dropped it all the
way down to 10. what the validation step
does is it says we have 2 000 photos in
our trainings or in our testing set and
we're going to use that for validation
well i'm only going to use a random 10
of those to validate so not really the
best settings but let me show you why we
did that let's scroll down here just a
little bit and let's look at the output
here and see what that what's going on
there so i've got my drawing tool back
on and you'll see here it lists a run so
each time it goes through an epic it's
going to do 4 000 steps and this is
where the fourth out comes in so that's
we have we have epic one of ten four
thousand steps is randomly picking half
the pictures in the file and going
through them and then we're gonna look
at this number right here that is for
the whole epic and that's 2411
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures talking an hour and a half
per epic times 36 or no 25 they had 25
up above 25 so that's roughly a couple
days a couple days of processing well
for this demo we don't want to do that i
don't want to come back the next day
plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs
point nine gigahertz per second for a
laptop it was good about four years ago
but for running something like this is
probably a little slow so we cut the
times down and the last one was
validation we're only validating it on a
random 10 photos and this comes into
effect because you're going to see down
here where we have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss
very important numbers to look at so the
10 means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important we'll just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and you know
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and see what that looks like in
code and put that in our jupyter
notebook all right and let's paste that
in here and we'll start by importing
numpy as np numpy is a very common
package i pretty much imported on any
python project i'm working on another
one i use regularly is pandas they're
just ways of organizing the data and
then np is usually the standard in most
machine learning tools as a return for
the data array although you use a
standard data array from python and we
have cross pre-processing import image
fish that all look familiar because
we're going to take a test image and
we're going to set that equal to in this
case cat or dog one as you can see over
here and you know let me get my drawing
tool back on so let's take a look at
this we have our test image we're
loading and in here we have test image
one and this one hasn't data hasn't seen
this one at all so this is all new oh
let me shrink the screen down let me
start that over so here we have my test
image and we went ahead and the cross
processing has this nice image set up so
we're going to load the image and we're
going to alter it to a 64 by 64 print so
right off the bat we're going to cross
is nice that way it automatically sets
it up for us so we don't have to redo
all our images and find a way to reset
those and then we use also to set the
image to an array so again we're all in
pre-processing the data just like we
pre-processed before with our test
information training data and then we
use the numpy here's our numpy that's uh
from our
right up here important numpy as in p
expand the dimensions test image axes
equal zero so it puts it into a single
array and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and we have
a second picture over here let's just
see what happens when we run the second
picture we can go up here and change
this uh from dog image one to two we'll
run that and it comes down here and says
cat you can see me highlighting it down
there as cat so our process works we
you're able to label a dog a dog and a
cat a cat just from the pictures there
we go cleared my drawing tool and the
last thing i want you to notice when we
come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see that has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of one well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happen to come up one now when they
ran this on the server it actually came
up about 86 percent this is why cutting
these numbers down so far for a
commercial release is bad so you want to
make sure you're a little careful of
that when you're testing your stuff that
you change these numbers back when you
run it on a more enterprise computer
other than your old laptop that you're
just practicing on or messing with and
we come down here and again you know we
had the validation of cat and so we have
successfully built a neural network that
could distinguish between photos of a
cat and a dog imagine all the other
things you could distinguish imagine all
the different industries you could dive
into with that just being able to
understand those difference of pictures
what about mosquitoes could you find the
mosquitoes that bite versus mosquitoes
that are friendly it turns out the
mosquitoes that bite us are only four
percent of the mosquito population if
even that maybe two percent there's all
kinds of industries that use this and
there's so many industries that are just
now realizing how powerful these tools
are just in the photos alone there is a
myriad of industries sprouting up and i
said it before i'll say it again what an
exciting time to live in with these
tools and that we get to play with let's
start with learning frameworks to start
with this chart doesn't even do the
filled
justice because it's just exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's a keras
which happens to sit on tensorflow so
they're very integrated there's
tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe theano
dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are
better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow let's see
what is tensorflow what is tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team for building machine learning and
deep learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but
when python is operating on one computer
and it has a float value and it
truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then on another it
doesn't this is one of the things that
tensorflow
addresses and does a very good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty
recent but it's a really nice tool to
have so you when you're working with
other people or showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company you can give
them a nice visual model so they know
what's going on what are they paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term this is the programming side
and it's really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation fraud detection video
detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor um that's what this is named
after so we talk about tensors in
tensorflow tensorflow is derived from
its core component known as a tensor a
tensor is a vector or a matrix of n
dimensions that represent all types of
data and you can see here we have the
scalar which is just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers uh might be a number in a
direction you have a simple matrix and
then we get into the tensor i mentioned
how a picture is a very complicated
tensor because it has your x y prints
and then each one of those pixels
has three to four channels for your
different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called
as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so that's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank three
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at
the basics of a neural network in
reverse propagation that is the basics
of tensorflow and then it goes through a
lot of different options and properties
that you can build into your different
tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs it has
nodes that represent the operations in
your model and if you
look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs b c and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus 4
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more you can actually one of
the tensors is a neural network with
reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic
flow of computations of the data going
across and you can see we can plug in
the numbers b equals four c equals three
d equals six and you get x equals four
plus three
so x equals seven y equals six minus
four so y equals two and finally a
equals seven times two or a equals
fourteen like i said this is a very
simplified version of how tensorflow
works each one of these layers can get
very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these models to see how they work
now tensorflow has gone through two
stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
x fit
y train and then your validation data
your x value y value and your epics and
your batch size all that goes into the
fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean if
you remember from the beginning i said
cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.cross cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them be doing classification
the other one might be doing just linear
regression kind of stuff or a neural
basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated tensor you have
coming in but all of it's very easy to
do and that's what 2.0 does a really
good job of and here we have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph uh in the api cleanup
tensorflow 1 you could build models
using tf gans tf app tf contrib tf flags
etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version uh tensorflow
1 0 the python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like in the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models uh neural network kind
of set up
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 of your
time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
once you have all that set up you have
your distribution strategy where are you
going to run it you're going to be
running it on just your regular cpu are
you going to be running it with the gpu
added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu set up in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package you
might need to run this on some really
high processors because you're
processing at a server level for uh
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done every minute
um and so you need that higher speed to
give them a
to give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
um talking about an affordable way to
beta test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of end
and now they also have other language
bindings so you can now create your
tensorflow backend save it and have it
accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant
5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way you can
create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is two
three which is then going to create a
nice two by three
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf dot add x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work
whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects we're going to stick with
jupiter notebook
pycharm whatever it is you're going to
use in here you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note um it's kind of hard to see but i
have my main
pi 3 6.
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3 6.
if you have python version 37 or 3 8
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your tensorflow or if you're in
anaconda you can do a conda install
tensorflow to make sure it's in your
package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just
demo for the right size go under new
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
uh or something along those lines so
it's always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array um a
equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the ray
right in there
six one
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where you can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you round you surround it in
print and you can see it's a tf tensor
it has the shape the type and the and
the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
uh we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here uh you'll
see right here when i print them both
out what happens is it only prints the
last one unless you use print commands
uh so important to remember that in
jupyter notebooks we can easily fix that
by go ahead and print and surround v
with brackets and now we can see with
the two different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work uh so those are a couple of things
to note in here and just like any other
array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf dot concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out uh you'll see right here we end
up with a tensor so let's put it in as a
constant not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
um axes
zero is going to be your first one and
axes one is going to be your second one
and it translates as columns and rows if
we had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about is
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis one you know zero one two that's
going to be our columns uh and if you
can do columns then we also can do rows
and that is simply just changing the
concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axes1
to axis 0 and if we run that you'll see
that now we concatenate by row as
opposed to column
and you have 4 3 6 1 7 8 4 7 so it just
brings it right down and turns it into
rows versus columns you can see the
difference there your output this really
you want to look at the output sometimes
just to make sure your eyes are looking
at it correctly and it's in the format i
find visually looking at it is almost
more important than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy format as far as
python is concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling uh one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer 32. if i go to
the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a tf float 16 in
this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32-bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with
zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tensor row is masked
you know zero is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four maybe we
want to swap that to four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down and just for fun let's go back up
here where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill you a lot of times
you fill these with random numbers and
so this is the random dot uniform is one
of the ways to do that now i just talked
a little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by a
hundred and then round it off or
whatever you want to do there's a lot or
then convert it to an integer was one
way to round it off
uh kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take this
same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor uh and then we're gonna go ahead
and print
our
tensor
let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo copy and paste works
fine but sometimes be aware that copy
and paste can copy the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry enter 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did uh
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a
transform uh so when we come down here
it's all done for you and so there's so
many times you have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma two
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array um but instead
we're going to do just a two by one
array and the code for that is your tf
dot matte mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
um oh let's do some multiplication
that's always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 20 32 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically um your main values
on the diagonal being ones and zeros
across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows uh two
columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the script for that got a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions so we're
going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how
kara sits on top of it and the different
aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning sci pi sci pi is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the
seaborne as sns is going to be set on
top of our matplot library which we
import as mpl and then of course we're
going to import our matplot library pi
plot as plt and right off the bat we're
going to set some graphic colors um
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
and then we're going to take we have our
mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
um and then our map plot library is
going to be inline this is a jupiter
notebook thing the matplot library in
line and then warnings we're going to
filter our warnings and we're just going
to ignore warnings that way when they
come up we don't have to worry about
them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it uh we
just brought in the math probably should
have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick
recall on that and so in cross uh we
have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going one
tensorflow layer at a time you go kind
of look at think of it as going from
left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where cross and
tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers um
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here we had
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers
and our dense layers you have an input
layer a dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our psi kit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
and let's go ahead and take a quick look
at that this is in open office it's just
a standard you know like we can do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns a number of rows it
actually goes down to like eight
thousand
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down
probably not something we're going to
work with
the second row
is bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same we have a date so we
have a sequential order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 ring so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm tim
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames equals pd.read csv
and then our the path to it just happens
to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
this looks very similar to what we were
just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
um
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at
we're looking at the number we're
looking at the profile which is the ben
dung the
date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done
three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
panda now i talk about this all the time
so i know i've already said it at least
once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our
date time it's come in in two columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
panda's data frame
and tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combined date
time
and then i always like to
print we'll do df head
just we can see what that looks like and
so when we come out of this we now have
our setup on here and of course it's
edited on to the far right here's our
date time you can see the format's
changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column
and we've brought the date over and
we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 1
here well that doesn't look good so we
need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that
uh to do that uh to finish combining our
date time let's go ahead and create a a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame how
do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
so that it looks right on here and you
know it just takes time to get through
all that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a scent
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and do you have now reorganized this so
we put in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before
and you'll see the date time now has our
0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want and in the right
sequential order
and if we go back to um there we go our
air quality uh you can see right here
we're looking at um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation uh minimum amount
maximum amount we have our first quarter
second quarter and third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1
we can simply do the quantile 0.25
percent
which should match
our 25 percent up here and we'll be
looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down for
each
different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here um
clean out some of our
we're going to draw a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values in the
first row is just our titles so that's
important it's important to drop those
rows in here and so this right here as
we look at our different quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through all of our columns and
this way we can look at each uh column
individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science uh things we can look at
that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now uh we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3 so we've broken it down uh we
have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go back
up here here's our f8 we've rounded it
off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times iqr and the iqr is your q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters this
is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck happened
here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
uh that means something's going wrong
there and they usually in this case is
going to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project
just to find the outliers because you
want to know
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iqr x
equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x uh
max iqr is 100 percent
min iq r is min iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column uh then we're
going to go ahead and convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
hum
uh you can see here it's this is just
cleanup
we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers and
we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left
linears it's going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
uh same thing with this up here with the
um df2i interpolate that's what we're
doing
again this is all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data uh
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and and use
a logarithmic function on the temp value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not
what i go look at i don't look at air
care data in fact this is probably the
first air care data set up i've looked
at but the experts come in there and
they come to you and say hey in data
science this is a exponentially variable
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
a figure figure size here's our plt from
matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas and this is a chart you would
send back to your data analysis and say
hey is this what you wanted this is how
the data is converting on here as a data
sciences scientist the first thing i
note is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale
to 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself
has kind of been
adjust it a little bit based on some
kind of a skew on there so let's jump
into uh we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set uh
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 of the data make
sure it's an integer we don't want to
take a slice as a float value give you a
nice error
uh and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
that are going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
set up in here we create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here so we're going to do the look back
one here's our train x our train y and
it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y and so what we're looking
at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for
what are we looking for well we want to
look back one that's the um what we're
going to train the data with is
yesterday's data yesterday says hey the
humidity was at 97
what should today's humidity be at if
it's 97 yesterday
is it going to go up or is it going to
go down today if 97 does it go up to 100
what's going on there uh and so our
we're looking forward to the next piece
of data which says hey tomorrow's is
going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
uh so we're going to add another reshape
on here let me just go down here and put
it into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more
level on here instead of being 1299.1 we
want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
um and this could have depends again on
how far back in the long short term
memory you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one 1
129 1 1
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one
again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x and then our y is just
a single column because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for
so now we've done our eighty percent um
you know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
um
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model and if you
remember sequential it just goes in
order that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
layer two or layers zero to layer one
this is different than functional uh
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory uh and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and uh there's let me go ahead and put
the next model in there uh because we're
going to do two models and the next
model is going to go ahead and we're
going to do dent so we have model equal
sequential
add a dense model and if you remember
from the very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an
lstm now just about every tensorflow
model uses dents uh your dense model is
your basic
forward propagation uh reverse
propagation error or it does reverse
propagation to program the model so any
of your neural networks you've already
looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays oral networks the
convolution usually uses a relu um your
sigmoid all the way up to soft mac soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead and if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on
long short-term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
uh we built all our different you know
we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which will use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any
scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model
uh so what are we doing in here we're
going to send in our train x our train y
uh we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this um i'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different uh when you
process this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics um you might
try to know what this number is as a
data scientist where i haven't had the
phd level math that says this is why you
want to use this particular batch size
you kind of play with this number a
little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this um
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations uh but yeah a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
you know even with a a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that we'll pull
the process on there more across
multiple um processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're
retraining the stuff over again it's
kind of good to know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there uh
so we can test to see how good it did
uh when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction
we know it has a certain amount of error
and we want to compare the error we have
on what we programmed it with with the
error we get when we run it on new data
that's never seen the model's never seen
before and one of the things we can do
go ahead and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals an np
exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1 for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score uh which is
your math square root times the mean
square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before
this is how good my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
uh
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we go ahead and go with that
and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this uh
we're going to go ahead and shift the
train predictions for plotting we have
our train predict plot
uh
np empty like data set train predict
plot
set it up with uh null values
yeah
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here
so we have our train predict plot
uh which is going to be our look back
our length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops it
looks like i put it in here double no
it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
this is where the problem was is because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our
ax1 that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
uh test prediction plot we're going to
make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth
set our ticks up this actually just puts
time axes gets its ticks
the little little marks there going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty does pretty good it's pretty
right on you can get a good idea what to
expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows and that is to build
this sequential model and we're only
putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times uh
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation and i
worked for two weeks to figure that out
well as a data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and data analytics is going to look
for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course
with any data science putting out a
pretty graph so that your shareholders
again we want to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
in this video i will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some parts for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use an existing neural network
model so we are not going to chain a new
one because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobilenet that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as uh
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import
download and import that and then we
will actually use that model in our code
all right so these two cells we have
downloaded and import the model and then
once it is available locally we will
then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we're actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which can turn
our images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so
we can read and write videos using that
and the video that we are going to use
is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this import file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and um you know actually we will be
reading the video profile but then we
will be analyzing the name and we will
be reading them at 10 frames per second
that is the rate we are mentioning here
and analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a file named something
like this traffic underscore annotated
and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated
video this might take a little while so
i will pause the video after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
always make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hold the resources so it's very
similar for the end of it the list piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video
go back to my file manager so this was
the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here it just got each of these
cars are getting detected let me pause
and show you so we pause here it says
car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there's uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and uh even when the cat moves a
little bit in the other direction it
will continue to detect and show that it
is a cat okay so yeah so this is how the
original video is let's go ahead and
change our code to analyze this one and
see if it detects our network detects
this cat close this here we go and
go back to my code all we need to do is
change this traffic to capture extension
it will automatically pick up because it
is given here and it will run through so
very quickly once again what it is doing
is this video reader video on this
reader has a neat feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will
run this cell again it will take a
little while so the hourglass has come
back i will pause and then come back in
a little while all right so the
processing is done let's go and check
the annotated video go here so we have
get annotated dot mp4 let's play this
all right so you can see here just
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see
yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continue to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
convolution
neural network tutorial do you know how
deep learning recognizes the object in
an image and really this particular
neural network is how image recognition
works it's very central one of the
biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image
don't worry we're going to get into the
details so we have our input layer
accepts the pixels of the image as input
in the form of arrays and you can see up
here where they've actually labeled each
block of the bird in different arrays so
we'll dive into deep as to how that
looks like and how those mixes are set
up your hidden layer carry out feature
extraction by performing certain
calculations and manipulation so this is
the part that kind of reorganizes that
picture multiple ways until we get some
data that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
we'll look into that a lot closer here
so if you're if it's a little confusing
now we'll dig in deep and try to get you
squared away with that and then finally
there is a fully connected layer that
identifies the object in the image so we
have these different layers come through
in the hidden layers and they come into
the final area and that's where we have
a one node or one neural network entity
that lights up that says it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the cnn what is
convolution neural network how cnn
recognizes images we're going to dig
deeper into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the cnn we'll
begin our introduction to the cnn by
introducing the pioneer of convolutional
neural network jan lecoon he was the
director of facebook ai research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called lynette in
1988. so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits
processing mail and automating that
process cnn is a feed forward neural
network that is generally used to
analyze visual images by producing data
with a grid-like topology a cnn is also
known as a convent and very key to this
is we are looking at images that was
what this was designed for and you'll
see the different layers as we dig in
near some of the other some of them are
actually now used since we're using
tensorflow and karass in our code later
on you'll see that some of those layers
appear in a lot of your other neural
network frameworks but in this case very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see the flowers two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more team beautiful and the rose smells
quite beautiful of a couple rose bushes
in my yard they go into the input layer
that data is then sent to all the
different nodes in the next layer one of
the hidden layers based on its different
weights and its setup it then comes out
and gives those a new value those values
then are multiplied by their weight
and go to the next hidden layer and then
you have the output layer and one of
those nodes comes out and says it's an
orchid and the other one comes out and
says it's a rose depending on how it was
well it was trained what separates the
cnn or the convolutional neural network
from other neural networks is a
convolutional operation forms the basis
of any convolutional neural network in a
cnn every image image is represented in
the form of arrays of pixel values so
here we have a real image of the digit
8.
that then gets put on to
its pixel values represented in the form
of an array in this case you have a
two-dimensional array and then you can
see in the final in form we transform
the digit 8 into its representational
form of pixels of zeros and ones where
the ones represent in this case the
black part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
step and look at matrixes in this case
we're going to simplify it and we're
going to take two matrices a and b of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learned that
you want to focus just on the matrix
aspect of this and then we'll bring that
back together and see what that looks
like when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have in this case our
single dimension matrix and we have a
equals 537597
and we have b equals one two three so in
the convolution as it comes in there's
gonna look at these two and we're gonna
start by doing multiplying them a times
b and so we multiply the arrays element
wise and we get five six six is three
times two and then the other six is two
times three and since the two arrays
aren't the same size they're not the
same setup we're going to just truncate
the first one and we're gonna look at
the second array more the first array
now that was gonna be a little confusing
remember a computer gets to repeat these
processes hundreds of times so we're not
going to just forget those other numbers
later on we'll see we'll bring those
back in and then we have the sum of the
product in this case 5 plus 6 plus 6
equals 17. so in our a times b our very
first digit in that matrix of a times b
is 17. and if you remember i said we're
not going to forget the other digits so
we now have 3 2 5 we move one set over
and we take 3 2 5 and we multiply that
times b and you'll see that 3 times 1 is
3 2 times 2 is 4 and so on and so on we
sum it up so now we have the second
digit of our a times b product in the
matrix and we can bond with that same
thing so on and so on so then we would
go from three seven five to seven five
nine to five nine seven this short
matrix that we have for a we've now
covered all the different entities in a
that match three different levels of b
now in a little bit we're going to cover
where we use math at this multiplying of
matrixes and how that works
but it's important to understand we're
going through the matrix of multiplying
the different parts to it to match the
smaller matrix with the larger matrix
i know a lot of people get lost at is
you know what's going on here with these
matrixes oh scary math not really that
scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to b so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so i'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and i'm
bringing the value down into one matrix
a times b we're reducing that
information in a way that will help the
computer see different aspects let's go
ahead and flip over again back to our
images
here we are back to our images talk
about going to the most basic two
dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
relu isn't how it act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that a
lot of other neural networks when you're
using it just by itself is for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network it's very commonly
used i like to use the term reduce so if
you're coming from the map and reduce
side you'll see that we're mapping all
this data through all these networks and
then we're going to reduce it we're
going to pull it together and then
finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only 0 and 1. now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter
is going to be derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have mini
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on the filter works as a matrix
remember earlier we talked about
multiple matrixes together and here we
have our two dimensional matrix and you
can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this so we're going to predict the first
one and slide it over one notch predict
the second one and so on and so on all
the way through until we have a new
matrix and this matrix which is the same
size as the filter has reduced the image
and whatever filter whatever that's
filtering out it's going to be looking
at just those features reduced down to a
smaller matrix so once the feature maps
are extracted the next step is to move
them to the relu layer so the relu layer
the next step first is going to perform
an element-wise operation so each of
those maps coming in if there's negative
pixels so it says all the negative
pixels to zero and you can see this nice
graph where it just zeros out the
negatives and then you have a value that
goes from zero up to whatever value is
coming out of the matrix this introduces
non-linearity to the network uh so up
until now we have a we say linearity
we're talking about the fact that the
feature has a value so it's a linear
feature this feature
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw you'll look
at that and say okay this feature has a
value from negative 10 to 10 in this
case if it was one it'd say yeah this
might be a beak it might not might be an
edge right there a minus five means no
we're not even going to look at it to
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these features all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with a
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix
one more aspect to note about the relu
layer is we're not just having one value
coming in uh so not only do we have
multiple features going through but
we're generating multiple relu layers
for locating the features that's very
important to note you know so we have a
quite a bundle we have multiple filters
multiple rail u which brings us to the
next step
forward propagation now we're going to
look at the pooling layer the rectified
feature map now goes through a pooling
layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose
so you have a rectified feature map
you see here we have a rectified feature
map coming in
we set the max pooling with a two by two
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time uh well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a step we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which is you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a 4x4 so
we're continually trying to filter and
reduce our data so we can get to
something we can manage and over here
you see that we have the max
3 four one and two and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now
finding the max value and then we're
pulling those features together so
instead of think of this as image of the
map think of this as how valuable is a
feature in that area how much of a
feature value do we have and we just
want to find the best or the maximum
feature for that area they might have
that one piece of the filter a beak said
oh i see a oneness beak in this image
and then it skips over and says i see a
three in this image and says oh this one
is rated as a four we don't want to sum
it together because then you know you
might have like five ones and it'll say
ah five but you might have uh four zeros
and 110 and that 10 says well this is
definitely a beak where the ones will
say probably not a beak a little strange
analogy since we're looking at a bird
but you can see how that pulled feature
map comes down and we're just looking
for the max value in each one of those
matrixes cooling layer uses different
filters to identify different parts of
the image like edges corners body
feathers eyes beak etc i know i focus
mainly on the beak but obviously each
feature could be each a different part
of the bird coming in so let's take a
look at what that looks like structure
of a convolution neural network so far
this is where we're at right now we have
our input image coming in and then we
use our filters and there's multiple
filters on there that are being
developed to kind of twist and change
that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a two by two we multiply it
by each piece of the image and if we
step two then it's every other piece of
the image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the relu setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
relu then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes multiple dimensions you can
have three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions uh so
right now we have 2d image dimensions
coming in into the pooling layer so the
next step is we want to reduce those
dimensions or flatten them so flattening
flattening is a process of converting
all of the resultant two-dimensional
arrays from pooled feature map into a
single long continuous linear vector so
over here you see where we have a pooled
feature map maybe that's the bird wing
and it has values 6847 and we want to
just flatten this out and turn it into
6847 or a single linear vector and we
find out that not only do each of the
pooled feature maps we do all of them
into one long linear vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the
input layer into the next setup all
we've done is taken all those different
pooling layers and we flatten them out
and combine them into a single linear
vector going in so after we've done the
flattening we have just a quick recap
because we've covered so much so it's
important to go back and take a look at
each of the steps we've gone through the
structure of the network so far we have
our convolution where we twist it and we
filter it and multiply the matrixes we
end up with our convolutional layer
which uses the relu to figure out the
values going out into the pooling as you
have numerous convolution layers that
then create numerous pooling layers
pulling that data together which is the
max value which one we want to send
forward we want to send the best value
and then we're going to take all of that
from each of the pooling layers and
we're going to flatten it and we're
going to combine them into a single
input going into the final layer once
you get to that step you might be
looking at that going boy that looks
like the normal intuit to most neural
network and you're correct it is
so once we have the flattened matrix
from the pooling layer that becomes our
input so the pulling layer is fed as an
input to the fully connected layer to
classify the image and so you guys our
flattened matrix comes in in this case
we have the pixels from the flattened
matrix fed as an input back to our
toucan or whatever that kind of bird
that is i need one of these to identify
what kind of bird that is it comes into
our ford propagation network and that
will then have the different weights
coming down across and then finally it
selects that that's a bird and that it's
not a dog or a cat in this case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix and the two matrixes multiplied
all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers of
different filters then goes through the
relu as this activation and that creates
our pooling and so once we get into the
pooling layer we then and the pooling
look for who's the best what's the max
value coming in from our convolution and
we take that layer and we flatten it and
then it goes into a fully connected
layer our fully connected neural network
and then to the output and here we can
see the entire process how the cnn
recognizes
a bird this is kind of nice because it's
showing the little pixels and where
they're going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relu for the
pooling the pulling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification in the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps we have one two three four five
different steps going on here with sub
steps in there we're going to break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
cnn we'll be using the c410 dataset from
canadian institute for advanced research
for classifying images across 10
categories unfortunately they don't know
whether it's going to be a toucan or
some other kind of bird but we do get to
find out whether it can categorize
between a ship a frog deer bird airplane
automobile cat dog horse truck so that's
a lot of fun and if you're looking
anything in the news at all of our
automated cars and everything else you
can see where this kind of processing is
so important in today's world and very
cutting edge as far as what's coming out
in the commercial deployment i mean this
is really cool stuff we're starting to
see this just about everywhere in
industry so great time to be playing
with this and figuring it all out let's
go ahead and dive into the code and see
what that looks like when we're actually
writing our script
before we go on let's do uh one more
quick look at what we have here let's
just take a look at data batch one keys
and remember in jupiter notebook i can
get by with not doing the print
statement if i put a variable down there
it'll just display the variable and you
can see in our data batch one for the
keys since this is a dictionary we have
the batch one label data and file names
so you can actually see how it's broken
up in our data set so for the next step
or step four as we're calling it uh we
want to display the images using matte
plot library there's many ways to
display the images you can even uh well
there's other ways to drill into it but
matplot library is really good for this
and we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupiter notebook i need
to do the map plot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.pipelot
as plt and if you remember plot library
the pie plot is like a canvas that we
paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign matplot library inline
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as np for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch 1. so this will
pull in all data going into the x value
and then because this is just a long
stream of binary data uh we need to go a
little bit of reshaping so in here we
have to go ahead and reshape the data we
have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct this is kind of an interesting
thing it took me a little bit to i had
to go research this myself to figure out
what's going on with this data and what
it is is it's a 32 by 32 picture and let
me do this let me go ahead and do a
drawing pad on here so we have 32 bits
by 32 bits and it's in color so there's
three bits of color now i don't know why
the data is particularly like this it
probably has to do with how they
originally encoded it but most pictures
put the three afterward so what we're
doing here is we're going to take uh the
shape we're going to take the data which
is just a long stream of information and
we're going to break it up into 10 000
pieces and those 10 000 pieces then are
broken into three pieces each and those
three pieces then are 32 by 32. you can
look at this like an old-fashioned
projector where they have the red screen
or the red projector the blue projector
and the green projector and they add
them all together and each one of those
is a 32 by 32 bit so that's probably how
this was originally formatted was in
that kind of ideal things have changed
so we're going to transpose it and we're
going to take the three which was here
and we're going to put it at the end so
the first part is reshaping the data
from a single line of bit data or
whatever format it is into 10 000 by 3
by 32 by 32 and then we're going to
transpose the color factor to the last
place so it's the image then the 32 by
32 in the middle that's this part right
here and then finally we're going to
take this uh which is three bits of data
and put it at the end so it's more like
we do we process images now and then as
type this is really important that we're
going to use an integer eight you can
come in here and you'll see a lot of
these they'll try to do this with a
float or a float 64. what you got to
remember though is a float uses a lot of
mem which just goes up to 128 you are
just going to the the amount of ram let
me just put that in here is going to go
way up the amount of ram that it loads
uh so you want to go ahead and use this
you can try the other ones and see what
happens if you have a lot of ram on your
computer but for this exercise this will
work just fine and let's go ahead and
take that and run this so now our x
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we were
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that uh you'll see it doesn't oops i
said 128 it's 255. you'll see it doesn't
go over 255 because it's basically an
ascii character is what we're keeping
that down to we're keeping those values
down so they're only 255 0 to 255 versus
flow value which would bring this up
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matte plot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the map plot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image broken
down to the minimal pixels on there and
if we did the same thing oh let's do uh
let's see what one looks like hopefully
it's a little easier to see run on there
not enter let's hit the run on that
and we can see this is probably a semi
truck that's a good guess on there and i
can just go back up here instead of
typing the same line in over and over
we'll look at three that looks like a
dump truck unloading and so on you can
do any of the 10 000 images we can just
jump to 55
looks like some kind of animal looking
at us there probably a dog and just for
fun let's do just one more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four uh so you can
see we paid through all the different
images it's very easy to look at them
and they've been reshaped to fit our
view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're gonna start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a class uh cfar helper so it's
going to have an init and a setup for
the images and then finally we'll go
ahead and run that code so you can see
what that looks like and then we get
into the fun part where we're actually
going to start creating our model our
actual neural network model so let's
start by creating our one hot encoder
we're going to create our own here uh
and it's going to return an out and
we'll have our vector coming in and our
values equal 10. what this means is that
we have the 10 values in possible labels
and remember we don't look at the labels
as a number because a car isn't one more
than a horse maybe just kind of bizarre
to have horse equals zero car equals one
plane equals two cat equals three so a
cat plus a card equals what so instead
we create a numpy array of zeros and
there's gonna be ten values so we have a
ten different values in there so you
have
zero or one one means it's a cat zero
means it's not a cat um the next line it
might be that uh one means it's a car
zero means it's not a car so instead of
having one output with a value of zero
to ten you have ten outputs with the
values of zero to 1. that's what the one
hot encoder is doing here and we're
going to utilize this in code in just a
minute so let's go ahead and take a look
at the next helpers we have a few of
these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very applicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper which is a class and this is
a lot in this class so we'll break it
down here and let's just start some put
a space right in there there we go that
was a little bit more readable at a
second space so we're going to create
our class the cipher helper and we'll
start by initializing it now there's a
lot going on in here so let's start with
the uh init part uh self dot i equals
zero that'll come in a little bit we'll
come back to that in the lower part we
would initialize our training batches so
when we went through this there was like
a meta batch we don't need the meta
batch but we do need the data batch one
two three four five and we do not want
the testing batch in here this is just
the self all train batches so we're
gonna come make an array of all those
different images and then of course we
left the test batch out so we have our
cell dot test batch
we're going to initialize the train
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part since this is all just helper
stuff but breaking it up again makes it
easier to read it also makes it easier
when we start executing the different
pieces to see what's going on so that
way we have a nice print statement to
say hey we're now running this and this
is what's going on in here we're going
to set up these self training images at
this point and that's going to go to a
numpy array v stack and in there we're
going to load up uh in this case the
data for d itself all train batches
again that points right up to here so
we're going to go through each one of
these uh files or each one of these data
sets it's not a file anymore we've
brought them in data batch one points to
the actual data and so our self training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and it's always
nice to get the training length and
that's just the total number of uh self
training image in there and then we're
going to take the self training images
let me switch marker colors because i am
getting a little too too much on the
markers up here oops there we go bring
down our marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well when we
wanted to uh look at this above and we
want to look at the images in the
matplot library we had to reshape it so
we're doing the same thing here we're
taking our self training images and
based on the training length total
number of images because we stacked them
all together so now it's just one large
file of images we're going to take and
look at it as our our three video
cameras that are each displaying a 32 by
32 we're going to switch that around so
that now we have each of our images that
stays the same place and then we have
our 32 by 32 and then by our
three our last are three different
values for the color and of course we
want to go ahead and they run this where
we say divide by 255 that was from
earlier it just brings all the data into
zero to one that's what this is doing so
we're turning this into a zero to one
array which is all the pictures 32 by 32
by three and then we're going to take
the self training labels and we're going
to pump those through our one hot
encoder we just made and we're going to
stack them together and
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals one dog equals two
and then horse plus dog would equal 3
which would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of 10 where each one is 0 to 1. then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just changed colors here this is no
different than what we were doing up
here with our training set we're going
to stack the different images
we're going to get the length of them so
we know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we shape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand just to throw me for a little
loop when i'm working with tensorflow or
cross or a lot of these we have our data
coming in if you remember we had like 10
000 photos let me just put 10 000 down
here we don't want to run all 10 000 at
once so we want to break this up into
batch sizes and you also remember that
we had the number of photos in this case
a length of test or whatever number is
in there we also have 32 by 32 by 3. so
when we're looking at the batch size we
want to change this from 10 000 to
a batch of in this case i think we're
going to do batches of 100 so we want to
look at just 100 the first hundred of
the photos and if you remember we set
self i
equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create x we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialize we've actualized it for 0. so
we're going to look at x from 0 to batch
size which we set to 100 so just the
first 100 images and then we're going to
reshape that into
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3. now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
in the correct shape and then the y just
like the x
is our labels so our training labels
again they go from zero to batch size in
this case they do sell fi plus batch
size because the self is going to keep
changing and then finally we increment
the self i because we have zero so we so
the next time we call it we're going to
get the next batch size and so basically
we have x and y x being the photograph
data coming in and y being the label and
that of course is labeled through one
hot encoder so if you remember correctly
if it was say horse is equal to zero it
would be one for the zero position since
this is the horse and then everything
else would be zero in here let me just
put lines through there there we go
there's already
hard to see that array so let's go ahead
and take that and we're going gonna
finish loading it since this is our
class and now we're armed with all this
um uh our setup over here let's go ahead
and load that up and so we're gonna
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're gonna do dot
setup images uh now we could have just
put all the setup images under the init
but by breaking this up into two parts
it makes it much more readable and also
if you're doing other work there's
reasons to do that as far as the setup
let's go ahead and run that and you can
see where it says uh setting up training
images and little setting up test images
and that's one of the reasons we broke
it up is so that if you're testing this
out you can actually have print
statements in there telling you what's
going on which is really nice uh they
did a good job with this setup i like
the way that it was broken up in the
back and then one quick note you want to
remember that batch to set up the next
batch as we have to run
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you can see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float 64. nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to 255 value
or zero to one and do keep in mind that
zero to one value that we converted the
255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get a better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32. we just talked about the
float64 versus the numpy float we're
actually just going to keep this at
float 32 more than a significant number
of decimals for what we're working with
and since it's a base holder we're going
to set the shape equal to and we've set
it equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what that
first value is and then 32 by 32 by
three that we've reshaped our data to
fit in and then we have our y true
equals placeholder tf float 32 and the
shape equals none comma 10 10 is the
labels we have so it's an array of 10.
and then let's create one more
placeholder we'll call this a hold prob
or hold probability and we're going to
use this we don't have to have a shape
or anything for this this placeholder is
for what we call drop out remember from
our theory before we drop out so many
nodes is looking at or the different
values going through which helps
decrease bs so we need to go ahead and
put a placeholder for that also and
we'll run this so it's all loaded up in
there so we have our three different
placeholders and since we're in
tensorflow when you use keras it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct cross sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the
tensorflow so a lot of these already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our
init weights and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here now we're not going to be
doing that we're just going to recreate
them for our code and let's take a look
at this we have our weights and so it
comes in is going to be the shape and
what comes out is going to be a random
number so we're going to go ahead and
just admit some random numbers based on
the shape with a standard deviation of
0.1 kind of a fun way to do that and
then the tf variable init random
distribution so we're just creating a
random distribution on there that's all
that is for the weights now you might
change that you might have a higher
standard deviation in some cases you
actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant in this case we're using 0.1 a
lot of times the bias is just put in as
one and then you have your weights add
on to that uh but we're gonna set this
as point one uh so we wanna return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2d
because we're taking our data coming in
uh we're going to filter it strides if
you remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32
by
by 3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so let's take this number
here and combine it with the 32 by 32 so
this is a very important layer here
because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here uh it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre-formatting and the setup and then
you have your actual convolution layer
that goes through on there and you can
see here we have init weights by the
shape and knit bias shape of three
because we have the three different uh
here's our three again and then we
return the tfnn relu with the convention
2d so this convolutional has this
feeding into it right there it's using
that as part of it and of course the
input is the x y plus b the bias so
that's quite a mouthful but these two
are
the keys here to creating the
convolutional layers there the
convolutional 2d coming in and then the
convolutional layer which then steps
through and creates all those filters we
saw then of course we have our pooling
uh so after each time we run it through
the convectional layer we want to pull
the data if you remember correctly on
the on the pool side and just get rid of
all my marks it's getting a little crazy
there and in fact let's go ahead and
jump back to that slide let's just take
a look at that slide over here uh so we
have our image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go um you know the
filter is coming in here and it looks at
these four boxes and then if it's a step
let's say step two it then goes to these
four boxes and then the next step and so
on uh so we have our convolutional layer
we generate or convolutional layers they
use the relu function there's other
functions out there for this though the
relu is the
most the one that works the best at
least so far i'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was max
so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a one and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down reducing it down as small as
we can and then finally we're going to
flatten it out into a single array and
that goes into our fully connected layer
and you can see that here in the code
right here we're going to create our
normal full layer so at some point we're
going to take from our pooling layer
this will go into some kind of
flattening process and then that will be
fed into the full the different layers
going in down here and so we have our in
size you'll see our input layer get
shape which is just going to get the
shape for whatever's coming in
and then input size initial weights is
also based on the input layer coming in
and the input size down here is based on
the input layer shape so we're just
going to already use the shape and
already have our size coming in and of
course uh you have to make sure you
knit the bias always put your bias on
there and we'll do that based on the
size so this will return tf.matt mole
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything uh we get to do
all the easy part let's go ahead and
create our layers we'll create a
convolution layer one and two two
different convolutional layers and then
we'll take that and we'll flatten that
out and create a reshape pooling in
there for our reshape and then we'll
have our full uh layer at the end so
let's start by creating our first
convolutional layer we come in here and
let me just run that real quick and i
want you to notice on here the 3 and the
32. this is important because coming
into this convolutional layer we have
three different channels and 32 pixels
each
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 4 4 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max toolbar 2 2 and we put in the
convolutional 1 that we just created the
convolutional layer we just created goes
right back into it and that right up
here as you can see is the x is coming
in from here so it knows to look at the
first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up uh so matches
and we went ahead and ran this already i
think i read let me go and run it again
and if we're going to do one layer let's
go ahead and do a second layer down here
and it's uh we'll call it convo two
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional 2 and then from
convolutional 2 into convolutional 2
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer let's go ahead and we'll do since
we have 64 coming out of here and we
have a four by four going in let's do
eight by eight by 64. so let's do 4096.
this is going to be the flat layer so
that's how many bits are coming through
on the flat layer and we'll reshape this
so we'll reshape our
convo to pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means we'll go ahead and run this so
we've now created this variable the
convo too flat and then we have our
first full layer this is the final uh
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're gonna again use the
value for our setup on there on a neural
network for evaluation and you'll notice
that we're going to create our first
full layer our normal full layer that's
our definition so we created that that's
creating the normal full layer and our
input for the data comes right here from
the this goes right into it uh the convo
too flat so this tells it how big the
data is and we're gonna have it come out
it's gonna have uh 10 24 that's how big
the layer is coming out we'll go ahead
and run this so now we have our full
layer one and with the full layer one we
want to also define the full one drop
out to go with that so our full layer
one comes in uh keep probability equals
whole probability remember we created
that earlier and the full layer one is
what's coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full one drop out and 10 because
we have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 1024 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
drop out into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have two
feed into it and then you'd switch that
here for the y prediction for right now
this is great this particular data set
tried and true and we know this will
work on it and if we just type in y
predict and we run that uh we'll see
that this is a tensor object uh shape
question mark 10 d type 32 a quick way
to double check what we're working on so
now we've got all of our we've done a
setup all the way to the y predict which
we just did we want to go ahead and
apply the loss function and make sure
that's set up in there
create the optimizer and then uh trainer
optimizer and create a variable to
initialize all the global tf variables
so before we dive in to the
loss function we'll point out one
quitting or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups
we pointed out up here we can change the
4 4 and use different numbers there the
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 5 12. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function so we're going
to create a cross entropy loss function
and so before we discuss exactly what
that is let's take a look and see what
we're feeding it
we're going to feed it our labels and we
have our true labels and our prediction
labels
so coming in here is where the two
different variables we're sending in or
the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these are
incorrect so how much of it matches
and we're going to look at that we're
just going to look at the average that's
what the mean the reduced to the mean
means here so we're looking at the
average error on this
and so the next step
is we're going to take the error we want
to know our cross-entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it we feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms are most popular used so our
optimizer is going to equal the tf train
atom optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop it back into here here's our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights and your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out
and it has all its weights and then the
error is being prop sent back through
and reverse on our neural network so we
take this error we adjust these weights
based on the different formulas and this
is the atom formula is what we're using
we don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by 0.001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training
variable or function and this is going
to equal our optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more
variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global tf variables and when we look at
this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensorflow and then
initializes those variables so it's kind
of like a magic wand because it's all
hidden in the back end of tensorflow all
you need to know about this is that you
have to have the initialization on there
which is an operation
and you have to run that once you have
your setup going so we'll go ahead and
run this piece of code and then we're
going to go ahead and train our data so
let me run this let's load it up there
and so now we're going to go ahead and
run the model by creating a graph
session graph session is a tensorflow
term so you'll see that coming up it's
one of the things that throws me because
i always think of graphics and spark and
graph as just general graphing uh but
they talk about a graph session so we're
going to go ahead and run the model and
let's go ahead and walk through this uh
what's going on here and let's paste
this date in here and here we go so
we're going to start off with it with a
tf session as s so that's our actual tf
session we've created uh so we're right
here with the tf uh
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off that we're
initializing our variables here and then
we have for i in range 500. so what's
going on here remember 500 we're going
to break the date up and we're going to
batch it in at 500 points each we've
created our session run so we're going
to do with tf session as session right
here we've created our variable session
and then we're going to run and we're
going to go ahead and initialize it so
we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created um that
initializes our our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for i in range of 500 patch
equals ch.nextbatch
so if you remember correctly this is
loading up
100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing what is
that 500 times 100 is uh 50 000. so
that's 50 000 pictures we're going to
process right there and the first
process is we're going to do a session
run we're going to take our train we
created our train variable or optimizer
in there we're going to feed it the
dictionary we had our feed dictionary
that we created and we have x equals
batch 0 coming in y true batch 1
hold the probability 0.5 and then just
so that we can keep track of what's
going on we're going to every 100 steps
we're going to run a print so currently
on step format
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf.equal tf argument y
prediction 1 tf.org max y true comma one
so we're going to look at this is how
many matches it has and here our acc uh
all we're doing here is we're going to
take the matches how many matches they
have it creates it generates a chart
we're going to convert that to float
that's what the tfcast does and then we
just want to know the average we just
want to know the average of the accuracy
and then go ahead and print that out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screens there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run
so let's see what happens on my old
laptop and we'll see here that we have
our current uh we're currently on step
zero it takes a little bit to get
through the accuracy and this will take
just a moment to run we can see that on
our step 0 it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out he's actually reading that
backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to one the more accuracy we have so you
can see here we've gone from a point one
to a point three nine
and we'll go ahead and pause this and
come back and see what happens when
we're done with the full run all right
now that we've
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first we've defined
accuracy
the reason i got it backwards before is
you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal in fact that's
pretty much
you know unheard of and the same thing
with loss if you have a loss of zero
that's also unheard of the zero's
actually on this this axis right here as
we go in there so how do we interpret
that because you know if i was looking
at this and i go oh 0.51 that's uh 51
you're doing 50 50. no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage this is log
rhythmic what that means is that 0.2 is
twice as good as 0.1 and when we see 0.4
that's twice as good as 0.2 real way to
convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this at 50 percent we're just
guessing equals 0.1 and if 50
roughly equals 0.1 that's we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.1028 the accuracy of 50
percent then 75 percent is about 0.2 and
so on and so on don't quote those
numbers because it doesn't work that way
they say that if you have point nine
five that's pretty much saying a hundred
percent and if you have a anywhere
between you'd have to go look this up
let me go and remove all my drawings
there
so the magic number is 0.5 we really
want to be over a 0.5 in this whole
thing and we have
both 0.504 remember this is accuracy if
we were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over a 0.5 is pretty valid that means
this is pretty solid and if you get to a
0.95 then it's a direct correlation
that's what we're looking for here in
these numbers you can see we finished
with this model at point five one three
five so still good um and if we look at
uh when they ran this in the other end
remember there's a lot of randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights they got 0.5251 so a little
better than ours but that's fine you'll
find your own comes up a little bit
better or worse depending on just that
randomness and so we've gone through the
whole model we've created we've trained
the model and we've also gone through on
every 100th run to test them to see how
accurate it is
welcome to the rnn tutorial that's the
recurrent neural network so we talk
about a feed forward neural network in a
feed forward neural network information
flows only in the forward direction from
the input nodes through the hidden
layers if any into the output nodes
there are no cycles or loops in the
network and so you can see here we have
our input layer i was talking about how
it just goes straight forward into
layers so each one of those connects and
then connects the next hidden layer
connects to the output layer and of
course we have a nice simplified version
where it has a predicted output the
refer to the input is x a lot of times
in the output as y decisions are based
on current input no memory about the
past no future scope why recurrent
neural network issues in feed forward
neural network so one of the biggest
issues is because it doesn't have a
scope of memory or time a feed forward
neural network doesn't know how to
handle sequential data uh it only
considers only a current input so if you
have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now whatever i put as an
output
it's going to affect the next one um a
feat just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process was
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produce data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
in the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like printing the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second it's like three terabytes a
day of data so we're going to look at
one stock just analyzing one stock is
really tricky in here we'll give you a
little jump on that so that's exciting
but don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
rnn is natural language processing text
mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using rnn for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than
ice if i said processing language
natural leap so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you might get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself be
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess denoted by the
flags i have a flag i own it no um but
they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have our
propagation forward neural network the
input layers the hidden layers the
output layer with the recurrent neural
network we turn that on aside so here it
is and now our x comes up from the
bottom into the hidden layers into y and
they usually draw very simplified x to h
with c as a loop
a to y where a b and c are the
perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward bound
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on ht minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h to t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x a
t going in so it's the last output of h
combined with the new input of x where h
t is the new state fc is a function with
a parameter c that's a common way of
denoting it ht minus 1 is the old state
coming out and then exit t is an input
vector at time of step t well we need to
cover types of recurrent neural networks
and so the first one is the most common
one which is a one to one single output
one to one neural network they're kind
of a just a real basic flavor but
because it's very basic a lot of times
they'll call it the vanilla neural
network uh which is not the common term
but it is you know kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to many so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have mini to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs
examples sentiment analysis where a
given sentence can be classified as
expressing positive or negative
sentiments and we looked at that we were
discussing if it rains look for a
rainbow so positive sentiment where rain
might be a negative sentiment if you're
just adding up the words in there and
then the course if you're going to do a
one-to-one mini to one one to many
there's many to many networks takes in a
sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations if
you're a translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem while training an rnn your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as finishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice
image lots of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word
in the sentence or something like that
or it doesn't quite follow the full
logic of what you're working on
bloating gradient problem oh this is one
that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long training
time poor performance bad accuracy and
i'll add one more in there your computer
if you're on a lower end computer
testing out a model will lock up and
give you the memory error explaining
gradient problem consider the following
two examples to understand what should
be the next word in the sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the air like you do with any
neural network and looking for that
missed word maybe we'll have the person
took my bike and blank was a thief and
the student who got into engineering
with a blank were from asia consider the
following example the person who took
the bike so we'll go back to the person
who took the bike was blank a thief in
order to understand what would be the
next word in the sequence the rnn must
memorize the previous context whether
the subject was singular noun or a
plural noun so was a thief is singular
the student who got into engineering
well in order to understand what would
be the next word in the sequence the rnn
must memorize the previous context
whether the subject was singular noun or
a plural noun and so you can see here
the students who got into engineering
with blank were from asia it might be
sometimes difficult for the error to
back propagate to the beginning of the
sequence to predict what should be the
output so when you run into the gradient
problem we need a solution the solution
to the gradient problem
first we're going to look at exploding
gradient where we have three different
solutions depending on what's going on
one is identity initialization so the
first thing we want to do is see if we
can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally
there's a lot of choices out there and
then finally there's long short term
memory networks the lstms and we can
make adjustments to that so just like we
can clip the gradient as it comes out we
can also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call long term dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text i have been staying in
spain for the last 10 years i can speak
fluent maybe you said portuguese or
french no you probably said spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of saying to predict
the last word in the text it's possible
that the gap between the relevant
information and the point where it is
needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer ls tms's also have a chain-like
structure but the repeating module has a
different structure instead of having a
single neural network layer are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior ls tmss also have
a chain-like structure but the repeating
module has a different structure instead
of having a single neural network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating in a very special way as
you can see the deeper we dig into this
the more complicated graphs get in here
i want you to note that you have x of t
minus one coming in you have x of t
coming in and you have x at t plus one
and you have h minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus one going out
and of course uh on the other side is
the output a um in the middle we have
our tangent h but it occurs in two
different places so not only when we're
computing the exit
t plus one are we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x at t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing in the lstms that we look at
the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first up in the lstm
is to decide which information to be
omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x of t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus one and
then exit t plus of course you have a
bias in there with any of our neural
networks so we have a bias function so f
of t equals forget gate decides which
information to delete that is not
important from the previous time step
considering an stm is fed with the
following inputs from the previous and
present time step alice is good in
physics john on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output john
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this is the forget gate realizes
there might be a change in context after
encountering the first full stop
compares with the current input sentence
of x a t so we're looking at that full
stop and then compares it with the input
of the new sentence the next sentence
talks about john so the information on
alice is deleted okay that's important
to know so we have this input coming in
and if we're going to continue on with
john then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to john and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on john's so that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is the sigmoid
function and the other is the tangent h
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through 0 or 1. tangent h
function gives a weightage to the values
which are passed deciding their level of
importance minus 1 to 1. and you can see
the two formulators that come up the i t
equals the sigmoid of the weight of i a
to t minus one x of t plus the bias of i
and the c of t equals the tangent of h
of the weight of c of h of t minus one x
of t plus the bias of c so our i of t
equals the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input
at x of t john plays football well he
told me yesterday over the phone that he
had served as a captain of his college
football team that's our input input
gate analysis the important innovation
john plays football and he was a captain
of his college team as important he told
me over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute
but as a human being if i wanted to get
this information from a conversation
maybe it's a google voice looking in on
you or something like that
how do we weed out the information that
he was talking to me on the phone
yesterday well i don't want to memorize
that he talked to me on the phone
yesterday or maybe that is important but
in this case it's not i want to know
that he was the captain of the football
team i want to know that he's served i
want to know john plays football and he
was a captain of the college football
team those are the two things that i
want to take away as a human being again
we measure a lot of this from the human
viewpoint and that's also how we try to
train them so we can understand these
neural networks finally we get to step
three decides what part of the current
cell state makes it to the output the
third step is to decide what will be our
output first we run a sigmoid layer
which decides what parts of the cell
state make it to the output then we put
the cell state through the tangent h to
push the values to be between -1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of t we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of 0 of the h of t
minus 1 and back one step in time by the
x of t plus of course the bias the h of
t equals the outer t times the tangent
of the tangent h of c of t so our o t
equals the output gate allows the passed
in information to impact the output in
the current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the next word in
the sentence john played tremendously
well against the opponent and one for
his team for his contributions brave
blank was awarded player of the match
there could be a lot of choices for the
empty space current input brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun
john could be the best output after
brave thumbs up for john awarded play
the match and if you were to pull just
the nouns out of the sentence team
doesn't look right because that's not
really the subject we're talking about
contributions you know brave
contributions or brave team brave player
brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
starts looking at and goes oh no john is
what we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012
2016. we're going to try to predict the
stock prices of 2017. and this will be a
narrow set of data we're not going to do
the whole stock market it turns out that
the new york stock exchange generates
roughly three terabytes of data per day
that's all the different trades up and
down of all the different stocks going
on in each individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but you at
least you can give an ah you can give a
step forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm
let's dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start very familiar because it's very
similar setup let's take a look at that
and just a reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in bear
archives and uh
nice thing about anaconda especially the
newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python in different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows it
works fine on there you can go in here
and open a terminal window and then in
here once you're in the terminal window
this is where you're going to start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook
have set up a lot of stuff so that we're
ready to go kind of like martha
stewart's in the old cooking show so we
want to make sure we have all our tools
for you so you're not waiting for them
to load and if we go up here to where it
says new you can see where you can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually rename this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end and our pandas for our data set our
pandas as pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
um in fact depending on what your system
is since we're using cross i put an
overlap here
but you'll find that almost maybe even
half of the code we do is all about the
data prep and the reason i overlapped
this with uh cross let me just put that
down because that's what we're working
in uh is because cross has like their
own preset stuff so it's already
pre-built in which is really nice so
there's a couple steps a lot of times
that are in the kara setup we'll take a
look at that to see what comes up in our
code as we go through and look at stock
and the last part is to evaluate and if
you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the evaluate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here crossed
is a little bit more but when you're
working with some of the other packages
you might have like three lines that
might be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
hey this is what i did this is what it
looks like so let's go through those
steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the pd or panda read csv and it's
a google stock price train dot csv and
so under this we have training set
equals data set train dot i location and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on on here let's just take
a look at let's look at the actual file
and see what's going on there now if we
look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way you can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and i
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word padded text editor just so we
can take a look at it certainly you can
open up an excel or any other kind of
spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date uh
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price um
specifically is google this is the
google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do i
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
and the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we saw we start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open
and high which would be one and two
i'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and uh again i said the first half
is very boring whenever you hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scalar and when you look
at this you got to remember that biases
in our data we want to get rid of that
so if you have something that's like a
really high value let's just draw a
quick graph and i have something here
like the maybe the stock has a value one
stock has a value of a hundred and
another stock has a value of five
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min and then
everything else goes and then we change
this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between
one and zero so 100 equals one or one
equals a hundred and zero equals five i
can just multiply it's usually just a
simple multiplication we're using uh
multiplication
so it's going to be uh minus five and
then a hundred divided or 95 divided by
1. so or whatever value is is divided by
95.
and uh what we've actually created our
scale we've telling is going to be from
0 to 1 we want to take our training set
and we're going to create a training set
scaled and we're going to use our scalar
sc we're going to fit we're going to fit
and transform the training set uh so we
can now use the sc this this particular
object we'll use it later on our testing
set because remember we have to also
scale that when we go to test our
model and see how it works and we'll go
ahead and click on the run again uh it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1
and then as i is equal to 60 this value
is going to be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61 2 to 62 and so on and so on and
if you remember i said 0 to 60 that's
incorrect because it does not count
remember it starts at 0 so this is a
count of 60 so it's actually 59.
important to remember that as we're
looking at this and then the second part
of this that we're looking at so if you
remember correctly here we go we go from
0 to 59 of i and then we have a comma a
0 right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now i
know we did put it in there for one to
two
if you remember correctly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
um and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i to or i comma 0. if
you remember correctly this is 0 to 59
so there's 60 values in it uh so we do i
down here this is number 60. so we're
going to do this is we're creating an
array and we have 0
to 59.
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58. that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence uh here's
my open open open open open open what's
the next one in the series so we're
looking at the google stock and each
time it opens we want to know what the
next one uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we're going to take x-train and y-train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npraytrain we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly um so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um
in this case where's that value
16 by 11 99 1258 minus 60 1199 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the end layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment
but you do need the with the lstm you do
need the dropout and then the final
layer will be the dents but let's go
ahead and run this and they'll bring
port our modules and you'll see we get
an error on here and if you read it
closer it's not actually an error it's a
warning what does this warning mean
these things come up all the time when
you're working with such cutting edge
modules that are completely being
updated all the time we're not going to
worry too much about the warning all
it's saying is the
h5py module which is part of cross is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first
lstm layer in here we're going to have
units 50. the units is the positive
integer and it's the dimensionality of
the output space this is what's going
out into the next layer so we might have
60 coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and you have to tell it what shape
it's in well we already know the shape
by just going in here and looking at x
train shape so input shape equals the x
train shape of one comma one makes it
really easy you don't have to remember
all the numbers and put in 60 or
whatever else is in there you just let
it tell the regressor what model to use
and so we follow our stm with a dropout
layer now understanding the dropout
layer is kind of exciting because one of
the things that happens is we overtrain
our network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
that's not in that specific realm to fix
for that each time we run through the
training mode we're going to take 0.2 or
20 percent of our neurons and just turn
them off so we're only going to train on
the other ones and it's going to be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally i see a big difference as we
go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says oh 50 is coming out from our last
layer it's coming up you know goes into
regressor and of course we have our
dropout and that's what's coming into
this one and so on and so on so the next
three layers we don't have to let it
know what the shape is it automatically
understands that and we're going to keep
the units the same we're still going to
do 50 units it's still a sequel coming
through 50 units and a sequence now the
next piece of code is what brings it all
together let's go ahead and take a look
at that and we come in here we put the
output layer the dense layer and if you
remember up here we had the three layers
we had uh stm dropout and dents dense
just says we're going to bring this all
down into one output instead of putting
out a sequence we just know i want to
know the answer at this point and let's
go ahead and run that and so in here you
notice all we're doing is setting things
up one step at a time so far we've
brought in our way up here we brought in
our data we brought in our different
modules we formatted the data for
training it we set it up you know we
have our y x train and our y train we
have our source of data and the answers
where we know so far we're going to put
in there we reshape that we've come in
and built our cross we imported our
different layers and we have in here if
you look we have what uh five total
layers now cross is a little different
than a lot of other systems a lot of
other systems put this all in one line
and do automatic but they don't give you
the options of how those layers
interface and they don't give you the
options of how the data comes in cross
is cutting edge for this reason so even
though there's a lot of extra steps
building the model this has a huge
impact on the output and what we can do
with this these new models from cross so
we brought in our dents we have a full
model to get our regressor so we need to
go ahead and compile it and then we're
going to go ahead and fit the data we're
going to compile the pieces so they all
come together and then we're going to
run our training data on there and
actually create a regressor so it's
ready to be used so let's go ahead and
compile that and go and run that and if
you've been looking at any of our other
tutorials on neural networks we're going
to use the optimizer atom atom is
optimized for big data there's a couple
other optimizers out there beyond the
scope of this tutorial but certainly
that'll work pretty good for this and
loss equals mean squared value so when
we're training it this is what we want
to base the loss on how bad is our error
we're going to use the mean squared
value for our error and the atom
optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
into our fit fitting the rn into the
training set we have the regressor.fit x
train y train epics and batch size so we
know where this is this is our data
coming in for the x train our y train is
the answer we're looking for of our data
our sequential input epics is how many
times we're going to go over the whole
data set we created a whole data set of
x trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling the save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today because this isn't big enough to
cause a computer too much of a problem
to run not too straining on the
resources but as we run this you can
imagine what happened if i was doing a
lot more than just one column in one set
of stock in this case google stock
imagine if i was doing this across all
the stocks and i had instead of just the
open i had open close high low and you
can actually find yourself with about 13
different variables times 60 because
there's a time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
loading into your ram which will just
completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you're going to start running
into resource problems but for this we
don't have to worry about that so let's
go ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give a
second to kick in there there we go all
right so we have epic so this is going
to tell me it's running the first run
through all the data and as it's going
through it's batching them in 32 pieces
so 32 lines each time and there's 1198 i
think i said 11.99 earlier but it's
11.98 is off by one and each one of
these is 13 seconds so you can imagine
this is roughly 20 to 30 minutes run
time on this computer like i said it's
an older laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz
on a dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through and you can
see we've run it through 100 steps or
100 epics so the question is what does
all this mean one of the first things
you'll notice is that our loss can is
over here it kind of stopped at 0.0014
but you can see it kind of goes down
until we hit about 0.014 three times in
a row so we guessed our epic pretty
close since our losses remain the same
on there so to find out what we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test csv you see i've changed
the path on it for my computer and then
we'll call it the real stock price and
again we're doing just the one column
here and the values from eye location so
it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open stock open let's go ahead and run
that so let's load it in there and then
let's go ahead and create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this would all look familiar this is
the same thing we did before we're going
to take our data set total we're going
to do a little panda concat from the
dataset train now remember the end of
the dataset train is part of the data
going in and let's just visualize it
just a little bit here's our train data
and just put tr for train and it went up
to this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data so to find out we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test dilocation this is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and you
see we've labeled it to part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing that we
need to do is go ahead and read the data
in from our test csv you see i've
changed the path for my computer and
then we'll call it the real stock price
and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from i
location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the datastate
train now remember the end of the
dataset train is part of the data going
in let's just visualize it just a little
bit here's our trained data let me just
put tr for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
this value here is this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data because that's part of the next
data it's actually the top 59 so that's
what this first set up is over here is
we're going to do the real stock price
and we're going to just take the data
test and we're going to load that in and
then the real stock price is our data
test.test location so we're just looking
at that first column the open price and
then our data set total we're going to
take pandas and we're going to concat
and we're going to take our data set
train for the open and our data set test
open and this is one way you can
reference these columns we've referenced
them a couple different ways we've
referenced them up here with the one two
but we know it's labeled as a panda set
as open so pandas is great that way lots
of versatility there and we'll go ahead
and go back up here and run this there
we go and uh you'll notice this is the
same as what we did before we have our
open data set where pendant are two
different work and calculate our two
data sets together we have our inputs
equals data set total length data set
total minus length of data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're writing your test set versus your
training set you run completely separate
but when we graph this you'll see that
we're just going to be looking at the
part that we didn't train it with to see
how well it graphs and we have our
inputs equals inputs dot reshapes or
reshaping like we did before we're
transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and i finally went ahead and
take our x test and we're going to
create that x test and for i and range
60 to 80. so here's our x test and we're
appending our inputs i to 60 which
remembers 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test convert it to a numpy
array with the same reshape we did
before and then we get down to the final
two lines and here we have something new
right here on these last two lines let
me just highlight those or or mark them
predicted stock price equals regressor
dot predex x test so we're predicting
all the stock including both the
training and the testing model here and
then we're going to take this prediction
and we want to inverse transform so
remember we put them between 0 and 1
well that's not going to mean very much
to me to look at a float number between
001 i want the dollar amount so i want
to know what the cash value is and we'll
go ahead and run this and you'll see it
runs much quicker than the training
that's what's so wonderful about these
neural networks once you put them
together it takes just a second to run
the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matte plot library.pie plot as plt
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and plt is basically kind of
an object it's one of the things that
always threw me when i'm doing graphs in
python because i always think you have
to create an object and then it loads
that class in there well in this case
plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
we're gonna give that color red so it's
gonna be in bright red we're gonna label
it real google stock price and then
we're gonna do our predicted stock and
we're gonna do it in blue and it's gonna
be labeled predicted and we'll give it a
title it's always nice to give a title
to your uh graph if you're gonna present
this to somebody to your shareholders in
the office and the next label is going
to be time because it's a time series
and we didn't actually put the actual
digging times on here but that's fine we
just know they're incremented by pine
and of course the y label is the actual
stock price tlt.legend tells us to build
the legend on here so that the colorbad
and real good stuff price show up on
there and then the plot shows us that
actual wrap so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see here we have a nice graph
and let's talk just a little bit about
this graph before we wrap it up here's
our legend i'm telling you about that's
why we have the legend to show the
prices we have our title and everything
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we could put the actual time in
here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and um plotted the x since we
know what the the dates are and plotted
this to dates but we also know this only
the last piece of data that we're
looking at so last piece of data which
in somewhere probably around
here on the graph it's like about 20
percent of the data probably less than
that we have the google price and the
google price has this little up jump and
then down and you'll see that the actual
google instead of a turn down here just
didn't go as high it didn't go down so
our prediction has the same pattern but
the overall value is pretty far off as
far as um stock but then we can really
look at one column only looking at the
old price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like i was pointing
out earlier we talked about stock just
right off the bat for six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's weather uh shares then there's
the adjusted open adjusted high adjusted
low adjusted close they have a special
formula to predict exactly what it would
really be worth based on the value of
the stock and then from there there's
all kinds of stuff you can put in here
so we're only looking at one small
aspect the opening price of the stock
and as you can see here we did a pretty
good job this curve follows the curve
pretty well it has like a little jumps
on it bins they don't quite match up so
this bin here does not quite match up
with that bin there but it's pretty darn
close we have the basic shape of it and
the prediction isn't too far off you can
imagine that as we add more data in and
look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables might take a
little bit longer to train the data not
so good for doing a quick tutorial like
this in this video we will learn about
an important popular deep learning
neural network called generative
adversarial networks
yan lacoon one of the pioneers in the
field of machine learning and deep
learning described it as the most
interesting idea in the last 10 years in
machine learning in this video you will
learn about what are generative
adversarial networks and look in brief
at generator and discriminator
then we'll understand how gans work and
the different types of gans finally
we'll look at some of the applications
of gans
so let's begin
so what are generative adversarial
networks
generative adversarial networks or gans
introduced in 2014 by ian j goodfellow
and co-authors became very popular in
the field of machine learning
gann is unsupervised learning personal
machine learning it consists of models
that automatically discover and learn
the patterns and input data the two
models for generator and discriminator
compete with each other to analyze
capture and copy the relations within a
data set
dance can be used to delete new examples
that possibly could have been drawn from
the original data set
in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real
hundred rupee nodes the generator which
is basically a neural network generates
fake hundred rupees notes the
discriminator network will identify if
the nodes are real or fake let us now
understand in brief
about what is a generator a generator in
gans is a new network that creates fake
data to be trained on the discriminator
it learns to generate possible data the
generated instances become negative
training examples for the discriminator
it takes a fixed length random vector
carrying noise is input and generates a
sample now the main aim of the generator
is to make the discontinuities by its
output as real
the portion of the gap the brain
saturator includes
a noisy input vector the generator
network which transforms random input
into a data instance a discriminator
network which classifies the generated
data
a data for failing to dot the
discriminator the back propagation
method is used to adjust each weight in
the regulation by calculating the its
impact on the output the back
propagation method is used to obtain
gradients and these gradients can help
change the generator weights now let us
understand in brief what a discriminator
is a discriminator is a neural network
model that identifies real data from the
fake data generated by the generator the
discriminator's training data
comes from two sources
the real data instances such as real
pictures of birds humans currency notes
etc are used by the discriminator as
positive samples during the training
the fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process while
training the discriminator it connects
with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
discriminator loss in the process of
training the descriptor the screamer
classifies both real data and fake data
from the generator the discriminator
lost analyzes the descriptiveness of
misconception data instances fake or
fake data instance as real moving ahead
let's understand how bands work now cans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as g of x and a
discriminator is represented as d of x
they both play an exterior game where
the generator has to fully discriminate
by generating data similar to those in
the training set the discriminator tries
not to be fooled by identifying fake
data from the real leader they both work
simultaneously to learn and train
complex data like audio video or image
files now you are aware that gans
consists of networks generated geohex
now the data network takes a sample and
generates a free example of data the
generator is going to increase the
probability of the discriminator network
to make mistakes on the other hand the
discriminator network decides whether
the data is generated or taken from the
real sample using the binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that is the output in
the range zero and one here is an
example of a generated network trying to
identify if the hundred rupee nodes are
real or fake
so first
a noise vector or the input vector is
fed to the generator network the
generator creates fake hundred rupee
nodes
the real images of hundred rupee notes
stored in a database are passed to the
discriminator along with the fake nodes
the discriminator then identifies the
nodes and classifies them as real or
fake we train the model calculate the
loss function at the end of the
discriminator network and back propagate
the loss into both discriminator and
generator now the mathematical equation
of training again can be represented as
you can see here now this is the
equation
and these are parameters here represents
generator d represents the estimator now
p d of x is a probability distribution
of real data
p of z is the distribution of generator
x is the sample of probability data of x
z is the sample size from p of z d of x
is the discriminator network and g of
said
is the generator network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
object function such that d of x is
close to one and z of z is close to zero
it simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from
training set as real that is one and all
the generated images are fake that is
zero the generator wants to minimize the
objective function such that d of zero z
is one this means that the generator
tries to three images that are
classified scale that is one by the
discriminator network next
let's see the steps for training a
neural network so we have to first
define a problem and collect the data
then we choose the architecture of gan
now depending on your problem choose how
your band should look like then we need
to train the descriptor in real data but
that will help us predict them as real
for n number of times next you need to
generate fake inputs for the generator
after that you need to train the
discriminator on feed data predict the
generator data speed finally train the
generator on the output of discriminator
with the discriminations available
generator to full rescue meter let's now
look at different types of dance so
first we have vanilla gans now vanilla
gats have main max optimization formula
that we saw earlier where the
discriminator is a binary classifier and
is using sigmoid cross entropy loss
during optimization
in vanilla cans the generator and the
estimator simple
trunks the algorithm types optimize
mathematical equation using strategic
grade decent up next we have deep
convolutional dance or dc dance the dc
can support convolutional neural
networks instead of very large elements
at both discriminator and generator they
are more stable and generate higher
quality images the generator is a set of
convolutional layers with fractional
strided convolutions or transfer
convolutions so it runs samples the
input image at every convolutional layer
the discriminator is a set of
combinational layers with started
convolution so it down samples the input
image at every convolutional layer
moving ahead the third type you have is
conditional gas or sequence body ligands
can be extended into candy cell models
using an extra label information to
generate better results in c gan an
additional parameter called y is added
to the generator for generating the
corresponding data
labels are fed as input to the
discriminator to help distinguish the
real data from fake data generated
finally we have super resolution gans
now sr gans use deep neural networks
along with adversarial neural network to
produce higher resolution images super
resolution can generate a photorealistic
high resolution image but given relation
image let's look at some of the
important applications glance
so with the help of dc gans you can
train images of tactical characters for
generating faces of any characters and
pokemon characters as well next gas can
be used on the images of humans to then
make it realistic faces the faces that
you see on your screens have been
generated using dance and do not exist
in the led third application we have is
cans can be used to build realistic
images from extra descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals
we input a sentence and generate
multiple images fitting the description
here is an example of a text-to-image
translation using gans for a bird with a
black head yellow body and a sort beak
the final application we have is
creating 3d objects
so gans can generate 3d models using 2d
pictures of objects from multiple
perspectives gans are very popular in
the game industry dance can help
automate the task of creating three
characters and backgrounds to give them
errors to feel so we're gonna dive right
into what is cross we're also going all
the way through this to a couple
tutorials because that's where you
really lie as we roll up leaves so talk
about what
cross is a high level deep learning api
written python for easy limited
implementation of neural networks uses
deep learning frameworks such as
tensorflow pi torch et cetera is back in
to make computation faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast you get
confusing and having some kind of high
level order in there you can actually
view it and easily program these
different neural networks uh is really
powerful it's really powerful to have
something out really quick and also
testing your models and seeing where
you're going so crosswords by using
complex deep learning frameworks such as
tensorflow pytorch um you know played
etcetera as a back-end for fast
computation while providing a
user-friendly and easy to learn
front-end
and you can see here we have the
cross-api uh specifications and under
that you'd have like tf cross for
tensorflow thano cross and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top of
and this is i said organize everything
the heavy lifting is still done by
tensorflow or
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to dig as deeply into the heavy end
stuff while still having a very robust
package you can get up and running
rather quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it so the word principle of cross
uh the principle of crosses cross uses
computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions you
see here we put in blue they have the
expression expressing complex problems
as a combination of simple mathematical
operators where we have like the
percentage or in this case in a python
that's usually your left your remainder
or multiplication uh you might have the
operator of x to the power of 0.3 and it
uses useful for calculating derivatives
by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without really having not banging your
head and having to hand write everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems uh
specify input and outputs and make sure
all nodes are connected and so this is
really nice coming through is that as
your layers are going in there you can
get some very complicated different
setups nowadays we'll look at just a
second and this just makes it really
easy to start spinning this stuff up and
trying out the different models so we
look across models across model we have
a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation in any of these
setups this should look familiar you
should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is uh we have a layer that's dense layer
one as an activation now they're using
this particular example then you have
your name layer one layer dance relu
name layer two and so forth uh and they
just feed right into each other so it's
really easy just to stack and as you can
see here and it automatically takes care
of everything else for you and then
there's a functional model and this is
really where things are at this is new
make sure you update your cross or
you'll find yourself running this um
during the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and it uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross-input shape
equals 32 by by 32x3 you have your dense
layers dense 64 activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on you have two
different inputs
one way you can think of this is maybe
one of those is a small image and one of
those is a full-size image and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one node because it's
looking for one thing and then only into
one node for the other one and you can
start to get kind of an idea there's a
lot of use for this kind of split in
this kind of setup uh we have local
information coming in but the
information is very different even
though it overlaps you don't want to
send it through the same neural network
and everything that's trained faster in
this also has a better result depending
on how you split the data and how you
fork the models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in we have our
image inputs which is a 32 by 32 by
three or three channels or four if
you're having an alpha channel uh
you have your dens your layers density
for activation using the rayleigh very
common uh x equals dance inputs layers
that's 64 activation equals relu x
outputs equals layers dense 10
x model equals model inputs equals
inputs output outputs name equals minced
model
so we've got a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to have the input
go into different areas
so if you're already looking at cars you
probably already have this answer what
are neural networks uh it's always good
to get on the same page and for those
people who don't understand neural
networks to dive into that a little bit
or do a quick overview node networks are
deep learning algorithms modeled after
the human brain they use multiple
neurons which are mathematical
operations to break down and solve
complex medical problems
and so just like the neuron fires end
and it fires out all these other neurons
or nodes as we call them and eventually
they all come down to your output layer
you can see that really standard graph
input layer hidden layer and output
layer one of the biggest parts of any
data processing is your data
pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models they're kind of when you first
start using them like a black box you
put your data in you train it and you
test it and see how good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because that data in is bad outputs so
in data pre-processing we'll create our
own data examples set with keras the
data consists of a clinical trial
conducted on 2100 patients ranging from
ages 13 to 100 with the patients under
65 and the other half over 65 years of
age we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age and you can think of this in
today's world with a covid uh what's
going to happen on there and we're going
to go ahead and do an example of that in
our
live hands on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your uh setups i just like
those for doing demos and showing people
especially shareholders it really helps
this is a nice visual authority or
anaconda the anaconda has a lot of cool
tools they just added uh abm watson
studio clad into the anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook um i'm gonna do jupiter
notebook for this because i use the lab
for like large projects with multiple
pieces because there's a multiple tabs
but they know but we're fine for what
we're doing and this one's on our
browser window because that's how
jupiter how it's our jupiter
set to run and we'll go under new create
a new python 3 and uh it creates an
untitled python we'll go and give us a
title and we'll just call this uh cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to rename that and the
first thing we want to go ahead and do
is
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
um i mentioned sklearn or your scikit if
you're installing this you learn okay
learn stuff it's a psychic you want to
look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with scalar toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to and
we'll go ahead and create some training
labels and train samples for training
our data
and then just note what we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this is kind of a fun thing you can do
we can change the code to mark down
and then markdown code is nice for doing
samples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's not what we're starting at
this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup uh i'm gonna do for i and
range i'm gonna go ahead and create if
you look here we have random editors
print the labels appends we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data
and if you if i mean you can certainly
ask for a copy of the code from simply
learning a copy of this or you can zoom
in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our examples of pin
i'm just using this i do this kind of
stuff all the time i was running a thing
on uh they had to do with errors
following a bell shaped curve on a
standard distribution error and so what
do i do i generate the data the standard
distribution error to see what it looks
like and how my code processes it so
that was a baseline i was looking for in
this we're just doing a generating red
data for our step on here
and we could actually go in uh put some
of the data up let's just do this print
we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first five pieces
of data see what that looks like and you
see the first five pieces of data and
our training samples is 395 41 68 19.
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is uh we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1 000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here one thousand numbers
we generated and we could also if we
wanted to find that out we could pick up
the length of it
and let's already do a shape kind of
thing and they're using lp
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo
go ahead and take our labels oh those
are train labels we also did samples
didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels uh let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero i
guess that's they have symptoms of one
symptoms zero none and so we want to go
ahead and take our train labels and
we'll convert it into a numpy array and
the same thing with our samples
let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle uh this is just a
feature you can do in uh right here put
my drawing thing on i didn't have one
earlier uh i can take the data and i can
shuffle it uh so we have our so it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
um we've already randomized it so it's
kind of an overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow
and you want to randomize it just to
make sure that you know the input
doesn't follow a certain pattern
that might create a bicycle model and
we're going to create a scalar uh scale
range minimum max scalar feature range
zero to one uh and then we go ahead and
scale the uh scaled train samples so
we're gonna go ahead and fit and
transform the data
uh so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data to
zero and one otherwise you create a bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated um if you actually start
multiplying stuff there's a lot of
application division going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias to how the model fits it and then
it will not fit as well and then one of
the fun things we can do in jupiter
notebook is that if you have a variable
you're not doing anything with it it's
the last one of the line it will
automatically print
we're just going to look at the first
five samples here it's just gonna print
the first five samples
and you can see here we go point uh nine
one nine five point seven nine one so
everything's between zero and one
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into let's use
wikipedia be careful don't quote
wikipedia on these things because you
get in trouble
particularly start back in 2011 google
brain built disbelief as a proprietary
machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product and
then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
we're at uh so when you see the
tensorflow setup
it's like a huge following there are
some other setups like um the scikit
under the sk learn has a little neural
network but the test flow is the most
robust one out there right now and cross
sitting on top of it makes it a very
powerful tool so we can leverage both
the cross easiness in which we can build
a sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow uh and
then we have the rest of this all ross
here from two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the cross connection and then you have
your tensorflow across models in more
sequential it's a specific kind of model
look at that just a second if you
remember from the files that means go
from one layer to the next layer the
next layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that uh and then we have
from tensorflow across layers we're
gonna import our activation and our
dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom uh this
is a big thing to be aware of how you
optimize uh your data when you first do
it adam's as good as any atom is usually
there's a number of optimizers out there
but atom is usually assigned to bigger
data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
again it's the end of the day you know
at the end of the story how good does
your model do and we'll go ahead and
load all that and then comes the fun
part um i actually like to spend hours
messing with these things
and uh
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
uh no it's made hours in four lines
that's not what we're talking about has
been hours for lines of code uh we have
here
explain that just a second we have a
model and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next and our first
layer is going to be your input
it's going to be called dense which is
uh you usually just dispense
your activation how many units are
coming in we have 16 what's the shape
what's the activation this is where it
gets interesting because we have in here
uh relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for what these mean
and how they function how does really
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
different activations
and just
some of it is just almost like you're
playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like an uh inverse tension
activation of the 10h activation takes
up a huge processing amount so you don't
see it a lot yet it comes up with a
better solution especially when you're
doing when you're analyzing word
documents and you're cognizing the words
and so you'll see the shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
um it'll crash the system you'll just
decline the process
and then you see things like softmax
softmax generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these we talked about it
lets me do this uh rayleigh there we go
relu has um a setup where if it's less
than zero it's zero and then it goes up
um then you might have it called lazy
setup or has a slight negative to it so
that the errors can translate better
same thing with softmax it has a slight
laziness to it so that air is translated
all these little details make a huge
front of your model um so one of the
really cool things about data science
that i like is you build your uh they
call you build to fail it's an
interesting uh design setup which i
forgot the end of my code here
the concept of butterflies you want the
model as a whole to work so you can test
your model out
so what you can do
you can get to the end you can do your
was it
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there and
see where did they do my tensorflow here
is right above me there we go we start
doing across interviews and stuff like
that is you need a full functional set
of code so that when you run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
you can start swapping in these models
and so when i say spend a huge amount of
time on pre-processing data is probably
80 of your programming time
um
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple muscle
here
uh here's our sequential here's our
layer output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built uh the
next thing we're gonna want to do is
we're gonna go ahead and train that
model
and so the next step is of course model
training and we come in here a lot of
times it's just paired with a model
because it's so straightforward it's
nice to print out the model setup so you
can have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
the setup is your learning rate uh so i
forgot to have an arrow
a lot of times the learning rate is set
to 0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate um can overfit and
underfit uh see we'll look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and under fitting that
are really worth reading once you get to
that point in understanding and we have
our loss um
sparse gotta give across entropy so this
is going to tell cross how far to go
until it stops and looking for metrics
of accuracy so we'll go ahead and run
that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit uh most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100 um
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we're going to fill
it uh we're going to go through 3x and
put the verbs of 2 and i'm just going to
run this and you can see right here
here's our epic here's our training um
here's our loss if you remember right
here we said the loss was it compiled
our data
there'd be a loss uh so it's looking at
source categorical across entropy this
tells us that as it goes how how how
much
how much does the
error go down
is the best way to look at that and you
can see here the lower the number the
pattern is going down and vice versa
accuracy we want let's see where's my
accuracy
value accuracy at the end
uh and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance
you can have 100 accuracy and your model
doesn't work because it's outfitted
again you won't look up overfitting and
under fitting models
and we went ahead and went through
30 epics it's always fun to kind of
watch your code going
to be honest i
usually uh
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code uh repress the warnings in the
printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
uh but we'll go ahead and do a separate
set on here
and this is just what we did above now
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here uh the only difference
is that
we already did our scalar up here well
that doesn't matter because the data's
gonna be across the same thing but this
should just be just transform down here
so hit transform now so you don't want
to refit your data
on your testing data
there you go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data easy to make especially on
an example like this where we're not
doing
um we're randomizing the data anyway so
it doesn't matter too much because we're
not expecting something weird
then we go into our predictions the
whole reason we built the model is we
take our model we predict and we're
going to do here's our excel data batch
size 10 verbose and now we have our
predictions in here and we can go ahead
and do a
oh we'll print
predictions and then i guess i could
just put down predictions in five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what we think is going to be what we
think is going to have uh symptoms or
not and the first thing we notice is
that's hard to read because we really
want a yes no answer uh so we'll go
ahead and just round up the predictions
using the our max the number max for
predictions or just go to zero one and
if you remember this is a jupiter book
so i'm gonna put the print i can just
put in uh run predictions and once
different five and you can see here zero
one zero zero zero so that's what the
predictions are that we have coming out
of this is no symptoms symptoms no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms and just
as we're talking about at the beginning
we want to go ahead and take a look at
this there we go confusion matrix is for
accuracy check um most important part
when you get down into the story how
accurate is your model before you don't
play with the model see if you get a
better accuracy out of it and for this
we'll go ahead and use the site kit
the sk learn metrics
scikit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graphic look at pictures
with a thousand words
um and we're gonna do plus cm for
confusion matrix y true equal to labels
white predict rounded predictions
we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not gonna spend too much time on
the plotting going over the different
plotting code
you can spend a couple of tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there uh but we do have here as we do
fusion matrix there's our cm our classes
normalize false title matrix c map is
going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh near
cmap titles all the different pieces
whether you put that marks or not the
marks the class is a color bar um so a
lot of different information here as far
as how we're doing the printing of the
confusion matrix you can also just dump
the confusion matrix up into c board and
real quick and output it's worth knowing
how to do all this you're doing a
presentation to the shareholders you
don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and uh let's go ahead and do this
we've got to put together our cn plot
labels go and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it um so our confusion matrix
our classes um confusion matrix let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
we have our basic setup uh no side
effects 195 had side effects 200 no side
effects that had side effects so we
predicted that
we've actually had side effects and
that's pretty good i mean i don't know
that too but you know that's five
percent error on this and this is
because there's two hundred years right
five percent is uh why these both by two
and five out of a hundred uh you do the
same kind of math up here numbers click
on the flags it's 15 and 1.95 not an
easily rounded number but you can see
here where they have 15 people
who particularly have no uh with no
expense side effects kind of set up on
there and these confusion matrix are so
important at the end of the day this is
really where where you show whatever
you're working on comes up and you can
actually show me this is how good we are
or not how messed up it is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts but you can see
here it's really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model summary
and we just put the layers on here that
we built with our model in this and we
went ahead and trained it and the
prediction now we get a lot more
complicated uh let me flip back on over
here because we're gonna do another
demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with cross after creating our samples
and labels we need to get across neural
network model we'll be working with a
sequential model which has three layers
and this is what we did we had our input
layer hidden layers and output layers
and you see the input layer uh coming in
uh was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output our
intercepted vermont so we're gonna go
ahead and go to a little more
complicated uh training our models
two-step process we first compile our
model and we train it in our training
data set uh so we have compiled
compiling converts code into a form
understandable by machine we use the
atom the last example the gradient
descent algorithm to optimize the model
and then we trained our model which
means it let it learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let's go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized uh we come down here and we
compile it so it tells it everybody
build this model and use it uh and then
we train it this is the part where we go
ahead and fit our model and put that
information in here and it goes through
the training on there and of course we
see all the data which is really
important to do and then you saw we did
the creating a confusion matrix with
carrass
um as our performance association future
majors to check the results a confusion
matrix breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
um and so you can see here's what we did
with the true positive false positive
true negative false negative
and that is what we went over down here
on the end we printed it out and we have
a nice print out of our confusion matrix
uh with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative and so blue
ones uh the biggest numbers because
those are the better side and then uh we
have our false predictions on here as
far as this one so i had no side effects
but we predicted
no side effects predicting side effects
and vice versa if gender learner is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
by simply learning click on the link in
the description to know more now uh see
me loading those with karass we're going
to dive into a more complicated demo um
before well if you broke it down we
randomized some data we created the
cross setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a little bit more fun is we're going to
do a face master with cross so we're
going to build a cross model to check if
a person is wearing a mask or not in
real time and this might be important if
you're in front of a store this is
something today which is um
might be very useful as far as some of
our making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
omask and let's start with a little bit
on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people and masks and
again if you want some of this
information a contact simply learn they
can see some of the information as far
as people with them without masks so you
can try it on your own and this is such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here so before i dive into the mass
detection uh talk about being in the
current with a code and think of people
wearing masks this particular example i
had to go ahead and update to a python
3.8 version it might have been a three
seven i'm not sure i kind of skipped
three seven and installed three eight uh
so i'll be running a three python three
eight um and then you also wanna make
sure your tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
uh layers with really split remember
correctly from back uh oh look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes uh
multiple layers um programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not and then saving that muscle we
can use it in real time so we're
actually almost a full um in the end
development of a product here of course
this is a very simplified version and a
lot more to it you also have to do like
recognizing where someone's face or not
all kinds of things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new python three
python three
it's working on it there we go
um and we're gonna go ahead and train
our mask what's called this train mask
we're gonna go ahead and train the mask
and save it
so it's now
say mask train mask detection not to be
confused with mapping data a little bit
different direction about our physical
mask on your face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
they're not getting too deep on the
imports we're just going to go ahead and
notice a few of them uh so we have in
here
there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here we have our image processing
and the image processing right here
underlining that uh deals with how do we
bring images in because most images are
like a square grid and then each value
in there has three values for the three
different colors
uh cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of working with that so you don't
have to do all the listening if you're
not going to go along uh the mobile net
average pooling 2d this again is how do
we deal with the images and pulling them
uh dropout's cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when you get more and
more into keras and tensorflow uh you'll
auto drop out certain notes that way
you'll get a better um the notes kind of
die and they find that they actually
create more bias and help and they also
add processing times remove them um and
we have our flattened that's where you
take that huge array with the three
different colors and find a way to
flatten it so it's just a
one-dimensional array instead of a two
by two by three uh dense input we did
that in the other one so that's a little
familiar oops there we go our input our
model again these are things we had on
the last one here's our optimizer with
our atom
um we have some pre-processing on the
input that goes along with bringing the
data in uh more pre-processing with
image to array loading the image this
stuff is so nice it looks like a lot of
work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is it does everything for you you're not
doing a lot of pre-processing deleting
the software to the pre-processing um
we're gonna be working with the specific
categorical
again this is a conversion from a number
to a category uh zero one does anything
like true false
minorizer same thing uh we're doing our
labels around and then there's our train
test split classification report um our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here not for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup and tensorflow above
uh the path this is part of
opencv and what's the tutorial going on
with the open cvs if you know more about
opencv
this software especially the second case
when we reload up the data and look up
the video camera we can do that on this
round um but this is part of the opencv
thing you'll see cp2 usually has a
reference uh but the utility system is
how you rotate around and stuff like
that
and resize them and then a map library
for plotting because it's nice to have a
graph tells us how good we're doing and
of course our numpy numbers array and
it's the state os access wow so there's
a lot of imports uh like i said i'm not
going to spend a little time going
through them uh but we don't want to go
too much into them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number effects to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate to the
negative 4.01 a lot of times 0.001 or
0.01
use this in that variation depending on
what you're doing how many epics and you
kind of play with the epics the epics is
how many times we're going to go through
all the data and now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process one of the
downsides of jupiter
is a jupiter isolated to a single kernel
so even though i'm on an eight core
processor uh with 16 dedicated threads
only one thread is running on this no
matter what so it doesn't matter uh so
it takes a lot longer to run even though
uh tensorflow really scales up nicely
and the batch size is how many pictures
do we load at once in process again
those are numbers you have to learn to
play with depending on your data and
what's coming in and the last thing
we're going to do is say directly with
the data set we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and you have pictures with mass they're
just images of people with mass on their
face uh and we have the opposite go back
up here without masks it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of skewed
because they try to format them into a
very similar uh setup on there so
they're
mostly squares you'll see something
slightly different on here and that's
kind of important thing to do on a lot
of these data sets
as close as you can to each other and
we'll actually run in the in this
processing of images up here and across
layers and importing and dealing with
images it does such a wonderful job of
converting these a lot of that we don't
have to do a whole lot with uh so you
have a couple things going on there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had a face
mask or no face mask those are the two
options and we're just going to load
into that we're going to pin the image
itself and the labels just create a huge
array uh you can see right now this
could be an issue if you had more data
at some point um thankfully i have a 32
gig hardware or ram
even that you could do with a lot less
of that probably under 16 or even eight
gigs would just load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on here
it's telling me about how we are going
to convert the size of the image so it
resizes all the images now our data is
all identical that comes in
you can see here with our labels we have
without mass without mass without mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
uh and then we need to change it to the
one not hot encoding
this is going to take our um
up here we had was it labels and data i
want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels and equal
a categorical list we'll run that and
again if we do uh labels and we just do
the last or the first 10 let's do last
10 just because
minus 10 to the end there we go just so
we can see where the other side looks
like we now have one that means they
have a mass one zero and zero and so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
zero one
so zero
is uh do they have a mask on zero do
they not have a mask on one so this is
the same as what we saw here without
mass one equals um the second value is
without max so with mass without mask
and that's just with interviewer data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
uh it causes issues as far as training
and setting it up so we always use the
one encoder if the values are not actual
uh linear factor regression values are
not actual numbers if they represent a
thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our training test x train y test y um
train split test data and we'll go ahead
and make sure it's going to be uh random
and we'll take 20 of it for testing and
the rest for um setting it up as far as
training their model this is something
that's become so cool we're training
these at uh they realize we can augment
the data what does augment mean well if
i rotate the data around and i zoom in i
zoom out i rotate it share it a little
bit flip it horizontally fill mode as i
do all these different things to the
data it is able to it's kind of like
increasing the number of samples i have
uh so if i have all these perfect
samples what happens when we only have
part of the face the face is tilted
sideways or all those little shafts
cause a problem if you're doing just a
standard set of data so we're gonna
create an augment in our image data
generator um which is gonna rotate zoom
and do all kinds of cool things and this
is worth looking at this image data
generator all the different features it
has um a lot of times i'll the first
time through my models i'll leave that
out because i wanna make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know you build the whole
process and then you start adding these
different things in uh so you can better
train your model and so we're going to
run this and then we're going to load uh
let's go ahead and you probably got an
error and put this piece in right here
um i haven't run myself guys in the back
did this we take our base model and one
of the things we want to do is we want
to do a mobile net v2 um and this this
is a big thing right here include the
top equals false a lot of data comes
into the label on the top row uh so we
want to make sure that that is not the
case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on top of
the base model uh we want to go ahead
and set that up
and you'll see a warning here kind of
annoying in the morning because it has
to do with the uh size of the pictures
and the way it's from shape um so
they'll switch things into defaults
saying hey we're gonna auto shape some
of this stuff for you you should be
aware that with this kind of imagery
we're already augmenting it by moving
around and flipping it doing all kinds
of things to it so that's not a bad
thing in this but another data it might
be if you're working for domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have our base model we're
going to do our head model equals our
base model output
and what we've got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pulse 77 head model
head model flattened so we're flattening
the data uh so this is all processing
and flattening the images and the
pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we already
talked a little bit about a dense
district you think about and then the
head model has a drop out of 0.5 uh what
we can do with the drop out
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model you
use all the notes but this drop certain
ones out and helps stop biases from
performing uh it's a really cool feature
in here they discovered this while back
we have another dense mode this time
we're using soft max activation lots of
different activation options here
softmax is a popular one for a lot of
things so is there a loo
and you know we do a whole talk on
activation formulas and why what their
different uses are and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the softmax for a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups is a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
output equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we'll loop over all the layers
in the base model and freeze them so
they will not be updated during the
first training process uh so for layer
and base model layers layers.trainable
equals false a lot of times you go
through your data you want to kind of
jump in part way through i i'm not sure
why in the back we did this for this
particular example but i do this a lot
when i'm working with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first set of 30 data
before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics and we
go ahead and compile our loss is going
to be the binary across entropy which
we'll have that print out optimizer for
opt metrics is accuracy same thing we
had before not a huge jump as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head run
now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic it takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so anytime the train next and
trading y go in there's some randomness
going on there and it's jiggling it
around what's going into our setup uh of
course we're batch sizing it uh so it's
going through everybody's up for the
batch values how many process at a time
and then we have the steps per epic uh
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our test x and test by where
we're sending that in
again it's validation one of the
important things to know about
validation is our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased if you have a
higher accuracy on your uh testing you
know you've trained it and your accuracy
is higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and it's over fitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's if it's done
processing looks like we've gone ahead
and gone through two epics again you
could run this through about 20 with
this amount of data and it would give
you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at two because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread so now that we've done
this we're going to need to evaluate our
model and see how good it is and to do
that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x to
see what it thinks are going to be uh so
now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then go ahead and go down
here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
either 0 or 1 it's a 0 1 0 1 so you have
two outputs uh not wearing wearing a
mask not wearing a mask and so we need
to go ahead and take that argument at
the end and change those predictions to
a
zero or one coming out and then to
finish that off we wanna go ahead and
just put this right in here and do it
all in one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with a mask there's
our f1 score support without a mask 97
so that's pretty high uh set up on there
you know you three people are going to
sneak into the store who are without a
mask and it thinks they have a mask and
there's going to be three people with a
mask that's going to flag the person at
the front oh hey look at this person you
might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's a setup in front
of a store um so there you have it and
of course one of the other cool things
about this is if someone's walking into
the store you take multiple pictures of
them um you know this is just an it
would be a way of flagging and then you
can take that average of those pictures
and make sure they match or don't match
if you're on the back end and this is an
important step because we're gonna this
is just cool i love doing this stuff uh
so we're gonna go ahead and take our
model and we're gonna save it uh so
model save mass detector dot model we're
gonna give it a name uh we're gonna save
the format in this case i'm gonna use
the h5 format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved
so now i can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say i want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well i just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can use it for whatever and
then if i get more information and we
start working with that at some point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user uh here we have a nice
graph you can see the training loss and
accuracy as we go through the epics we
only did the only shows just the one
epic coming in here but you can see
right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the scikit with
sklearn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why i run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't conversed all the
way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
uh we have our
mobilenet v2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have a load model that's where
most of this stuff's going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little open cv code at
you and we actually have a tutorial on
that coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting uh so we're going to
detect and predict a mask we have frame
face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
um and then there's a frame shape here
this is just our height versus width
that all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dna blob form image frame so this is
reformatting this frame that's going to
be coming in literally from my camera
and we'll show you that in a minute that
little piece of code that shoots that in
here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face dot set import blob
detections face net forward print
detections shape
uh so this is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're gonna send that in there and i'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's gonna be under face net
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mass network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever if you have a crowd of faces um
so we're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here and
probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our middle confidence
probably is pretty good
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an opencv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box uh the box sets
it around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around which we hope
it's gonna be the face extract the face
roi converted from bgr to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times i
forgot to check the order colors working
with opencv because there's all kinds of
fun things when red becomes blue and
blue becomes red uh then we're going to
resize it process it frame it face frame
setup again the face the cvt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it image to array
pre-process the input
append the face locate face start x dot
y and x boy that was just a huge amount
and i skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
opencv does a decent job of finding the
face and that box is going to go in
there and see hey does this person have
a mask on it
uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals mass net predict
faces batch size 32. so these different
images where we're guessing where the
face is are then going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the locations just tell us
where on the picture it is and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask all right so
we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that was saved
in obviously you're going to put in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one we
trained it
we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cv2.dnn
prototextpath weights path and we're
going to load that up on here let me go
ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling all the different pieces we
need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video setup
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
so we're going to go ahead and open up
our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some really
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos is that when you start
working with images and videos it's all
like right there in front of you it's
visual and you can see what's going on
uh so we're gonna start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means grabbing my main camera i
have hooked up
and then starting video you can print it
out here's our video source equals zero
start loop over the frames from the
video stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so
so while true we're going to grab the
frame from the threaded video stream and
resize it to have the maximum width of
400 pixels so here's our frame we're
going to read it from our visual stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame we're sending
it the face net and the mass net so
we're seeing all the different pieces
that say this is what's going through on
here
and then it returns our location
predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions um and the boxes is again
this is an opencv set that says hey this
is a box coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create a label no mask we
can create color if the label equals
mask l0 225 and you know it's going to
be a lot more sense when i hit the run
button here but we have the probability
of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
uh and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cb2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cv2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much so you're
ready for this to see if it works we've
distributed our our model we've loaded
it up into our distributed code here
we've got it hooked into our camera and
we're going to go ahead and run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky head set on
uh and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on i
wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
uh you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office on top of the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 chance
that i don't have a mask on and it's
true i don't have a mask on right now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an actual piece of script that
you can start you know you install
somewhere on a video feed on a security
camera or something and then you have
this really neat uh setup saying hey do
you have a mask on we enter a store or a
public transportation or whatever it is
we're required to wear a mask
let me go and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a hauler we will be
going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the open cv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross saving the
model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh demo
up above for just pulling in the cross
and we went into a cross model we pulled
in data to see whether someone was
wearing a mask or not so very useful in
today's world as far as a fully running
application and we're going to be going
over the opencv tutorial and it's going
to throw in some cross and we're
actually going to be covering a lot of
ground
in this tutorial so i'll speed up for
some of it and slow down as we focus on
important aspects we'll talk about
opencv um we're really talking about
computer vision uh so what is computer
vision
and i would say opencv goes way beyond
uh computer vision it goes into graphic
editors and all kinds of other things
i'm gonna be focusing a little bit on
computer vision and we're going to cover
the whole slew of the editors and other
cool stuff that's in there computer
vision is a field of machine learning
whose goal is to help computers see its
end goal is to make intelligent systems
which can understand digital images
and you can there's all kinds of
different examples from handwriting
identification categorizing of pictures
is that a dog or cat in the picture and
all that different things those are all
part of the computer vision um cars the
the new automated cars and being able to
drive down the road they usually use
aspects of computer vision to do that
for ais so what is opencv
uh opencv is a huge open source library
for computer vision machine learning and
image processing it can be used to
process images and videos to identify
objects faces or even handwriting of a
human
and one of the cool things is it's um
the opencv project is outside of python
but it has a high integration with
python so you can use it in other
programming languages you're not set to
just python with it and there's a huge
community behind it which is really nice
that's what makes the open cv project so
great let's start with installing the
opencv it's pretty straightforward in
python you do a pip install opencv dash
python uh you can pip install opencv you
can trip python headless
opencv can be installed in windows mac
os or any gnu linux distribution by
using the pip command the first one the
first command we went over is to install
the main module packages and the second
one is for the full package and usually
with the full package
once you start digging into it it's so
easy to use and so much fun things you
can play with so the most common thing
is reading in uh image in opencv and
we'll do this also in code so if i go a
little quick on the slides it's so that
we can roll up our sleeves and actually
open up and do the coding on there so
when we're reading an image in an opencv
given an image to load it in we can use
the opencv function i am read the image
can be displayed using the function i am
show
and so these are your two main
categories on here
uh and so the basic thing is to read an
image in then you can manipulate it and
then you can display it depending on
what you're using it for and then we'll
talk about manipulating it the most
common thing is probably resizing images
and videos so you can read in videos and
look at the command for that also now
you can process them frame by frame
resizing is uh helpful in all kinds of
aspects obviously on the display you
might want to resize it so if it's the
display a certain way a lot of times
it's handled um for the size of the
image if you're uploading it to the web
you might want to have a smaller image
so you're not taking up a huge amount of
memory uh not as big of a deal anymore
and then a lot of times the actual web
page would handle the size of the image
once you upload it but what if you want
to process all the images under the same
neural network well they're going to
look for the same size and that's also
huge just to be able to resize your
images to go into that neural networks
they're not looking at different sized
images an image just read in might not
be a correct size or might not fit the
screen correctly to overcome this we can
resize the image and you see it's a real
simple command in the um cv and we're
actually using what they call cv2 a lot
of times people just um they'll import
cv2 as or open cv2 and cv
just to make it easy uh because they
might have old code or something like
that it's easy to swap things in and
move forward
and you can see here we just resize we
have our image we have our new
dimensions and then how do we resize it
the interpolation is kind of a function
in there as far as how to guess the
colors because you're combining colors
and different things and we can use a
drawing with the opencv uh we can draw
images in opencv it allows us to draw
various things like rectangles circles
lines um you add text into the images
and that kind of thing so there's a
whole slew of different things we can do
with the opencv and we'll look at these
commands we'll glance through them and
show you how they work in the actual
software and they have basic image
functions
and
this is just so cool because so much of
this is built in you go back 10 years
and people are writing the code to do
this stuff and now it's all built in and
people are continually optimizing it so
you can do a lot of things without
having to lift the hood up and really do
the heavy lifting underneath uh so
opencv has built-in functions which
allow us to perform various operations
on our images such as blurring resizing
cascading edge detection cropping and
there's also motion detection and videos
all kinds of things um and you can see
here we have blurring we can take an
image and blur it slightly we can resize
it uh it's easy to crop it you know that
we do the round head face cropping on a
webpage or whatever
or identify where the object is and crop
the background out kind of thing and you
have image transformation we talked a
little bit just a second ago on blurring
we can also do things like rotating it
we can transform the image various ways
you can see here we can shift it so we
shift it left shift it right flip it
crop it um all of these are very easy to
do in the opencv package and then i
mentioned a little bit about we start
looking at motion detection and
detecting different things uh there's
contour detection which is built into
the opencv package which is really nice
and again this is stuff that
usually was somebody in the back in
programming this and now you have opencv
which does almost everything for you
so a contour is a curve or a line
joining all points which have the same
color intensity contours help us find
the points which lie on the same plane
and assist in edge detection and you can
see here we've taken the cat and done a
contour detection and it kind of looks
it makes it look almost like someone
stenciled it in there this is kind of
cool little zen art going on there
this is how the computer might using
contour detection see the cat on the
black background and then you also can
adjust the color channels so you can
play with all the colors any image is
basically a combination of three main
colors red green blue the rgb
sometimes
a quick note which we won't cover in the
programming is when you see that rgb
it's not always in that order there's
different formats for it and so there's
also sometimes the alpha channels you
might have rgba where a is how
transparent it is so you might actually
have four channels which i like to work
with when trying to take a background
out because the edges of images actually
have reflections
and light is also a curve and wraps
around so there's some cool things to
know when you're messing with these
things
and opencv allows us to split our image
into its respective color channels and
you can see here we've taken the image
of a
little landscape and we've sorted it out
into different channels and you can see
how you have all the blues the reds and
the greens there's also color spaces
color spaces are a way to represent the
color channels present in an image
they tell us the various color channels
which are contributing to a particular
hue
so again we can pull things out based on
the hue and the images and colors on
there
and blurring blurring is very popular
right now because it's easy to find
someone's face and then blur out the
background without having to play with
alpha channels and different things for
the coloring around the you know the
edging of the head and the coloring uh
so blurring is a method used to remove
noise from an image by applying a low
pass filter over an image we smooth out
the edges to make the transition from
one color to another very smooth
and you might not be able to see the
difference in the cat video but you
start seeing smoothness and sharpness
have always been
a mainstay of editing images and things
like that over the years and so this is
all built into opencv and then there's
bitwise operations bitwise operations
are the and or zor etc in image
processing they are used to create a new
image or for masking and we'll glance at
masking but masking is huge um so when
we get into the code we'll talk a little
bit more about masking i'll probably
maybe offshoot for a minute on that the
operation is done between each pixel of
two images
and so you can see here we have the
square
plus the circle so if it's an and
only where the white is so where it's in
both images it then equals a new image
with just the white parts and masking
masking is used to bring certain parts
of an image into focus by lowering the
definition over other parts this is done
by reducing the pixel quality of other
parts of the image kind of a little
short on the masking of what it is
so in this case the masking would either
be the background it might be all ones
and the cat in the fence might be zeros
or vice versa we might put the cat as
one in the background as zeros and then
you can do a
transformation on either the background
or the foreground to maybe you want to
blur the background out and make the
foreground sharper or maybe you want to
make the little circle with a cat in it
take the colors out so it's one color
masking allows you to separate your
image out and do those different things
that's where the masking comes in and it
has a lot of uses and then there's
histograms uh histograms in an image
processing histograms typically refer to
a graph of pixel intensity values the
intensity of each pixel is plotted in a
histogram again we start with these
histograms at the beginning of doing
different identifications and can be
used for different things
you don't really publish a histogram
onto your web page of the cats because
it's just kind of silly but you can use
that data in data processing to look at
different things and pull different
things out of the
uh picture
another important aspect of uh image
processing a method of image
segmentation it is used to convert an
image of binary by setting a threshold
intensity value and beaming all values
above it as one converted to white and
below a zero black and you can see here
we were talking about masks
in the threshold we're able to actually
create a mask of the image in this case
we have the cats which are mostly white
stand out because we put whatever the
value is
to pull those cats out and put the
background further back edge detection
uh just like threshold it's another tool
we can use to bring out an image
uh so we can find different things on
there a lot of cool things we can do
with that you can see here we've taken a
landscape uh same thing
we had before and we can find the
boundaries of an image by consistency
and brightness it's used for image
segmentation and data extraction and you
can see with this image of the buildings
how
powerful it is just to pull the whole uh
sky out and you know where the sky is
there's no debate on it
so finding edge detection has a lot of
cool things you can do when you're
processing images and pulling the images
apart so uh with that uh really the
hands-on there's so much hands-on on
this so we're gonna start with a real uh
basic opencv setup in python we'll then
take a look at some motion detection i
usually don't put the video on here
because my office is under construction
you can see the partially finished wall
in the back
um but when we do the motion detection
we'll have a video up and show you how
to pull this video in just like i'm
doing here and utilize that in a program
you can actually start detecting motions
you can think of a wilderness webcam or
something like that all kinds of fun
things you do with motion detection and
then we'll get into
building a little bit with the opencv
and write a
short cross
neural network that will train and do
facial identification so we're going to
cover just a slew of really cool tools
that you can do with opencv so here's my
favorite package to work in the anaconda
i'm going to be in python 3.8 and then
if you haven't yet you need to go under
environments you can either install them
through anaconda here or you can open up
let's see what's at 38. you can open up
your terminal and do the pip install
like we discussed earlier in the slide
and that was this slide right here pip
install open tv contrib python headless
i would just go right for the second one
because it installs everything uh so
it's a full package and you just go
ahead and open up in this case pi 38
there's my terminal window and i can
simply do my command in here
you can also
if you're in anaconda
we can go in here let's do all sorts of
packages for opencv
and you can see here's your opencv
library opencv python opencv and i
actually installed all of these all
these are installed on my on my anaconda
for the use of this um setup didn't want
to miss anything uh and then once we
open this up uh we're going to go in
here to new and create a new python
window python 3 in this case we're in
3.8 as i told you which is what's set up
in here
and we'll start with just uh opencv
general
so let's put that in here open cv
that's just a general setup on there for
doing our opencv
and
of course some people like to i'm not
big looking at my own face the whole
time during these but we're gonna put my
video back up there
and when we talk about the opencv uh
we wanna go ahead and import all of our
different aspects of what we're gonna be
working on in here
and you'll see on this we have our
import cv2 and i mentioned earlier that
a lot of people when they see the import
cv2 they just go ahead and automatically
do it as cv that way if you're using
older code
it doesn't bother me too much to use cv2
but a lot of people prefer to just keep
that as an open somebody'll probably
have cv3 who knows
we want our numpy for our numbers array
sometimes that comes in we have our
matplot library kind of by default and
we'll do our map plot library in line
just because we're in jupyter notebook
that way if we do any plotting it's not
really going to affect what we're
working on i just do it as a standard
pretty straightforward
and then before we get started let me go
ahead and pull over
we have a file set up on here with some
images in it and some videos
just like any of our other
setups in simply learn if you need a
copy of some of these images of course
it's pretty easy to come up with your
own images in your own videos nowadays
but if you want to rerun this and set
this up you can certainly have them send
the information over there with in this
case we have the cat which is going to
be an image we have a dog which is going
to be an mp4 uh video and then we have
we do facial recognition we took some of
our
very well known actors out there like
ben affleck elton john musician jerry
seinfeld and other people so we can
actually train a cross setup on there
and do a
facial recognition on there again all of
this you can send a simpler and say hey
can i get a copy of some of this
information
uh and so we're going to start out the
first we want to do is just the most
basic thing which is read in an image
and display it and then i'm going to go
ahead and let's see
i'm going to cut this in half
i used to have this in windows 10 where
i just hit a button and it dropped my
background and everything
so we're going to look at the horrible
blue color of the windows default
i'll just have to ignore my icons up
there and so we're going to be reading
images the reason i did a half screen
here is because
when they pop up they don't necessarily
pop up by default in front in the
jupyter notebook
so you're not even going to see them
they'd be hidden behind there the first
thing is just a basic reading of an
image in this case we're just going to
read the file cat.jpg there's no path in
here because i went ahead and saved it
in the same folder that the program's
running in but if you have a separate
folder you want to put that full path in
there and so it's real simple we have
image we have cm dot im read
or red i don't know which one to use um
i am red
and then cv i am show and it just stands
for image show and cats and then image
cats is the title of the window that's
going to pop up and let's go ahead and
run that and you can see here we have
our window that pops up and there's our
cat
so that's really straightforward
if you're looking at that
there's nothing
really difficult this is why i like
opencv so much it's so easy to use and
if we're going to do the image if you
remember we had dog
video going on we might image up a
little bit there we go
we can go ahead and play a movie and
that's that is really cool
by the way uh when i was messing with
this it does actually store the sound
file with the mp4 so if you have the
video playing and the microphone going
it will store both of those as a second
uh there's like another channel that
stores in the cv when it's reading
things in this case we're going to go
ahead and capture uh we need to go ahead
and tell it where what file we're
capturing um in the next video we'll
actually do
one of the next two sections we'll show
you how to capture the camera you're
actually looking at um but in this one
we have capture cb video capture dog.mp4
pretty straight forward it says here's
the file we're going to capture
and then it says while true
and this if you're doing
a lot of programming in python you
should recognize this
instead of
setting is true to true and then letting
it switch each time
we just say hey if not is true break and
it will break the loop and so what we're
doing here is we're going to read each
frame
of the video as it goes is true frame
equals capture dot red
if is true is false it breaks so we're
done at the end of the video and we're
going to show the video in this case of
a dog cute little puppy
and it's going to be by frame so each
frame is showing
and you see we have a weight key here
this has to do with uh the encode in the
back so
you could probably leave it out in here
but it's usually good to leave these
particular things in um
this particular key in there because it
does actually there are times when that
can affect the runtime and you can see
here's our little peppers you know
smiling and having fun
and it is it's playing each of those
frames so as you're watching it uh it's
going through i don't know how many
frames per second probably 30 frames per
second and so it's displaying 30 frames
one after another
um and if you have sound with it it by
default will play the soundtrack with
there just so you know um we don't we're
not doing too much in sound on this one
that we're just focusing on the opencv
video
and then when you're done with something
uh you'll see me flash this up a bunch
of times we're going to have the destroy
all windows from the cv which closes
everything we got going
when we're dealing with videos one of
the issues is you have a buffer in your
video and so you'll see us you'll see
this kind of coding where it says wake
key 60 and it's just waiting an extra
period of time to make sure everything's
cleared out of memory that's all that
does and so you can see we just closed
all the windows that came in on there
and then one of the cool things we can
do
and we're going to do a bunch of stuff
with images in just a minute but let's
start with the video we can do resizing
and so we have a rescale the frame we're
going to assume that the frame we're
going to submit the scale and it's going
to
compute the
height
the width and the height based on what
we send for a scale we'll put it into
dimensions and this right here is our
resize um see if resize is a frame and
this could also be an image not you're
not stuck with just a frame when you do
this kind of resize
and then they have this is a code they
use for resizing
not a whole lot to look in there it does
come up sometimes because there are a
couple different mathematical codes of
how to blend the colors together and
make it smaller without it
becoming really chunky or really i mean
they used to just delete like if you cut
it in half you just delete every other
pixel and then of course you're deleting
information instead of melding it
together and this moves it over that's
what this is doing right here this
interpolation equals cv enter area
uh and then we have the change the res
um we'll be doing a live video so um
when you change the res the resolution
again there's not a whole lot to look in
here it's just um helping us so that the
resolution keeps it looking nice on
there
and then we have our this should look
familiar from above we do our capture we
need to set up where the video is coming
from we gotta let the cv the opencv know
what the which file it's using
and then it says while true this is
again just like above if not true if not
is true break
and here's our frame resize
and then we're gonna do a cv im show
frame and we're going to do cv i am show
frame to resize this would look just
like you saw before and then we have our
this extra code here in case you need to
break early
now i'm going to run this and we're
going to get if you have if you're
looking at this you should say oh we
have um two different videos going one
of them is labeled video and it's based
on frame and one is video resize based
on frame so we're going to end up with
two completely separate videos playing
at the same time
and let's go ahead and run and see what
that looks like you'll know one of the
videos is obviously going to be the dog
because we saw him before and you can
see right here
there the dog is resized
and we could easily take this
scale
it will go this way just a little bit
and instead of 0.5 maybe we want to do
0.25 because we want it to be like a
little little um thumbnail on there let
me run that and you can see how it
nicely rescales it down to a quarter of
the size
and i'm going to keep the split screen
uh you'll see why in just a second let
me go ahead and destroy the windows and
clean up our desktop that we're working
on and we're gonna go back to image
editing uh so we're gonna go through a
bunch of image different editings you
can do one here
now this next part we're zooming through
there are so many things you can do with
the opencv uh first we're gonna just
draw a blank box i'm gonna run this
here's my blank box it's got nothing in
it
um and we can take if you notice i've
created blank oops there's my blank we
filled it with zeros so this is a 500 by
500 by three channel
there's actually can be four channels if
you have the alpha which is the
see-through uh and this will handle an
alpha channel but you have the three
channels in here and you create a nice
blank box that's just playing black and
in there uh and then if we're gonna do a
blank box we can actually take go back
in here there we go we're gonna take
this blank box and we're just going to
uh fill it i'll leave it called blank
we'll run this and i'm putting in from
200 to 300 that's actual pixel counts
remember this is a 500 by 500 box and
we're going to do from 200 to 300 and
300 to 400 that's the upper left and
bottom right corners of the array and
we're going to zero zero 255 which
happens to be green and this is rbg um
be a little careful because the some of
the formats switch the order from red
blue green to different colors
and if we run this uh you can see here
we've actually added i guess i did a um
a red box for some reason i thought that
was a green color i must have it
switched around on there
but you can see right here we can
actually go in and we can change any
pixel in here and it works like a numpy
array which is really nice because now i
can edit uh my blank box here and do
different things in the blank box and
fill it in there and draw lines
we'll go ahead and do
a rectangle like i said some of this
is going to be quicker to pasting in
here and showing you
we're going to take a rectangle and
oops it's hard to see here
create the shape let me open this up a
little wider there we go
and in the rectangle um
we're going to use blank
i'm going to show it we're going to give
it a new window that's what this is
doing down here if i left this blank you
just put the rectangle on top of
everything and we're going to use blank
as our basis i'm starting at 0 0
and you can see our different dimensions
and thickness minus 1 and there's my
weight key on the bottom and let me go
ahead and run that
i've just done an i am show uh which it
did behind our chrome
you can set where it appears on the
window we should probably do that on
here uh but you can see it opened up a
new window this window is called
rectangle this one's called blank and so
these are two completely different
windows that we've set up on here if i
change this to blank it would just put
the rectangle on top just like it did
the red square earlier
and we can do a lot with this we can go
ahead and draw let's see a circle a line
and then put some text on here and we'll
take the same blank setup since that's
our basis right here is blank
and we'll go ahead and create all of
those and let me go ahead and paste that
in here and you can see here we have
our cv circle that's going in on the
blank
we have our dimensions of the circle let
me just bring these down a line so you
can see a little bit better what we're
looking at there we go
um and then we're gonna do the color on
this the thickness minus one and this is
uh basically a radius of the circle kind
of set up i'd have to look up remember
the exact um what these different
numbers represent um but you have the
the different sizes of the circle we
have a line here we can draw a line
blank
in this case we have
300 400 255 and see it set up in here
says again the color the starting point
the endpoint and the thickness of three
so a lot of this is pretty
straightforward and this is going to
open up a new window called line because
that's what we called instead of putting
it on the blank
and then we'll do text
now on each one of these we're adding
the line to blank
so it's in the original blank square
that we call blank
but on each one of these we're putting
it opening up in a new window we can
easily continue to put them in the same
window and you can turn it into a video
or some other kind of thing
and you can see down here hello my name
is jason my name is actually jason
and we have our location we're going to
print json on there and
the font and the size and the color and
dimensions of it and then show text and
let's go ahead and run you can see how
all these show up on here
and if i open up my screen a little
wider uh you can see that we have our
code and we did certainly put add a
circle on here here's our circle we
added a line on here here's our line and
we've added text on here hello my name
is jason probably should have picked a
different color instead of matching it
with the square box we put on there
and just like all of this we want to go
ahead and clear the data um keep a nice
clean screen and i'm not sure if i keep
printing this stuff underneath let me go
fix that and then the next section we
want to cover is going to be your gray
scales and blending and masking and
stuff like that and let's go ahead and
clear our little palette i don't know
what else to call it
that's a good name for it palette
and here we go remember this one we're
going to load our image in this case
we're going to load the image park and
we're going to display park
we get the nice view of the park that's
what we did before and there's so many
things that are built into opencv on
here uh one we can grayscale it and
we're just going to take and you can see
here we're converting um blue green red
remember i said there's three channels
you gotta be a little careful what order
they're in i can never remember i have
to actually pull it up every time i go
in here because i jump around between so
many editors and software it's just the
nature of dealing with pictures
sometimes but you really have to make
sure you catch that and double check it
um and so we're just going to this is
just a conversion and that's what the
cvt stands for color and then we'll
display this in uh gray gray skeleton
and you can see it did a nice job
there's our park
oops i can grab it
and there's the grayscale on there
and then we can do such things as blur
so i can come in here and go ahead and
this uses cv gaussian blur and there's a
lot of settings as far as how the blur
works
and then you can see here we got border
default uh cv board default seven seven
i believe that has to do with the square
in the pixel range um when you do a lot
of blurring then you start messing with
it and we can see here's the park up
here
um we went ahead and grayscaled it oops
there we go uh grain not responding
because i hit the wrong button on this
and blur there's our blur on there so we
have a couple different setups on that
there's also edge cascade
some of these you just pretty much you
really have to know your editing on
videos i'm not a huge video editor so
when i do a lot of this stuff i'm not
really sure what it is i'm doing um like
i know a blur is obviously but i don't
know what edge cascade is
except for now that it comes out you can
clearly see that it draws lines dealing
with where the different colors meet and
how they connect that's a really neat
tool it puts a nice matte literally
creates a nice mask of the edging and
you can see where you could use this to
pull out in this case the sky quite
easily from the whole picture
and there's dilated let me go ahead and
run that and see what that looks like
let's give it a second to pop up to the
top
and keep in mind that the dilated used
the edge um as our input so we took um
the canny the blur oh there we go yeah
candy blur dilated use the candy so we
have our blurred coming in from the
candy edges
quite the terminology there if you're
trying to follow it all we have a
roading let me just show you some of the
settings on there
we have the number of iterations for
doing a roading so let's go ahead and
run this one
and you can see how it changes the
settings or the view on there and this
brought in the dilated and then eroded
it back into i'm guessing it kind of
sharpens it from the from the blurriness
we saw in the one before to dilate it
and then of course probably one of the
ones that i use the most and i use the
resize and the reason i use this a lot
is because i work in data science and so
if i have it coming in as a certain size
on there
if the if the neural network is
processing an image with a certain size
all the images coming in have to be that
size and so we have here resizing our
image
and let's go ahead and run that and you
can see how we took the
in this case we used the original image
and we just resized it to a smaller view
on there
and if we can resize the image we can
also crop it
again data science loves cropping this
is you could literally
crop pictures and resize them and rotate
them and make that your new import for
doing categorization
and we'll actually show you how we can
automate that when we get to the facial
recognition cross part of this tutorial
but we can see here we can also crop it
we just take the picture and crop a
small piece off of it there
and just like we did before let's go
ahead and clean our pallet start it over
again
and again we're just chugging through
these these are commands
that depending on what you're doing
depends on what you need so if we're
looking at um
changing it to grayscale uh sometimes
processing something in grayscale and
cross is easier it's able to pull out
the dimensions better blurring that's
more of a display kind of thing we're
going to play with this light blur
finding the edges that's kind of cool
you can actually come in there and maybe
use those edges to help you find
something in the foreground and in the
background
dilated give it a little blurry a look
eroded bring it back into sharpness
resize it and crop it all those are
things that are just neat tools to have
at your fingertips and easy to use
some of them might be more for a website
and bringing up icons and
cropping the headshot or something like
that where others are are kind of more
generally used in just about any
industry
another feature is being able to
translate
transmatt float32 remember a lot of
these things let me just full screen
this here real quick uh we have our
image coming in and then we can
translate it 100 in different directions
on here
there's so many different things we can
do with this so as we go through this oh
my goodness i
hit a button on here okay give me just a
second there we go okay so let's go to
the translators and translate on there
we have the cat and you can see how we
translate it down instead of the full
image of the cat that we had before we
can also rotate
rotation like i mentioned earlier is a
fun thing to do
and we'll actually do that we do the
cross thing because you can process the
same image at different angles and then
you just multiplied your input as far as
doing an identification
in this case you can rotate on here we
have the angle the rotation point
none i believe it puts it in the center
i have to look that up and then you have
the image shape height width rotate
point is none with height so this is
actually put the rotate point in the
middle if we send it to nuns is a little
routine that they put together in the
back
and then we're going to warp
this is the actual command here warp a
fiend
you have the image you have your rotate
map and you have your dimensions on here
and if we go ahead and plug that in we
put the rotate in
image at minus 45 let's see what happens
i'm going to run that
and you can see how it nicely rotated
the cat's head although it's a little
creepy the way it looks like it cut the
cat's head off on there maybe move it
translate it down a notch just so you
can't see the cutoff point
and we already did the resize but we'll
run that again so you can see how it
gets resized on here
and be aware when you resize them i do a
lot of resizing for the putting it into
neural networks or into some kind of
machine learning setup
but it does squish it it squishes it and
stretches it and so if you're doing this
for say display and re-editing you might
want to be a little careful about that
make sure that you maintain the same
ratio unless you intentionally want the
cat to look taller and thinner
and we can also go ahead and flip it as
you can see here we just flip it upside
down
minus one we can probably flip it a
couple different ways some carry system
minus two does
same thing
maybe if we put minus
and a one is well one is just flipping
it all the way to the opposite side from
left to right uh so you can see here we
can flip it around a little bit that's
kind of a fun thing to have um one of
those things you might have a hotkey for
if you're doing some kind of picture
editing and giving a lot of choices and
we also already did the
there we go cropping
as you can see here we a cropped image
equals the image and we just pick out
the pixels we want and then we can show
the cropped image over here and it's
just a cropping of the face in this case
we grab 200 to 400 as the upper left
corner and 300 to 400 as a bottom right
corner
and let's clear our palette again
and then we're going to do
contour detection and there is
so much that goes into all this i mean
we're flashing through a lot of things
and you can see how you might combine
them and use them for different things
so we're going to go ahead and get our
cat back up as our
image and let's go ahead and do um
image shape we're going to take an image
shape and we're just going to create a
blank screen for it uh so this is just a
blank screen here based on the shape of
the cat
and strangely enough uh this is done a
lot the reason that we create a blank
thing is you can or blank image is you
might start filling in information on
there and using that as your template
for different things
and so it becomes almost it becomes a
map of sorts uh mass in the program the
difference you can imagine that this
like screen you start with you might
have circles or squares or never on
there uh we can do the same thing here
without conversion grade did that
earlier which is kind of fun to see that
the cat comes back
and the thing that i'm missing with a
lot of uh different feeds and stuff like
that it's uh you can get another
responding going on there we need a lot
of stuff you'll start seeing more than
that as you mess with it it'll
eventually come in just to give them to
their desires
we have the gaussian blur so we can take
it and blow the image and this gets with
the third one so you can see that the
clear although the green one and the
more blurry one on top on there if you
remember that earlier
come back on here candy edges so again
we're doing detections and things like
that looking for different things
and there's another feature called cb
threshold uh or the threshed threshold
in this case we're going to send it a
great picture let me just pull the code
down here ah there we go and you can see
here we do a cv threshold based on
binary um let's set up on here we'll go
ahead and just run this you can see what
this looks like
there we go that's actually really cool
how except on that uh on the threshold
you can see how it just turns into a
black and white image that can be a lot
of fun too we also look at the contours
in the opencv
so we'll talk about that we have our let
me just open this up all the way so we
can see the code
we're going to turn the component and
the hierarchies
and we're going to pull this off of
canny the candy one we sent up here
earlier and
they have the retrieve list
and chain approximate samples there's a
lot of options in here that we can
follow let's go ahead and run that
let's go back down here where are you
there we go and we run this
uh we get a nice setup on this it says
hey there's 74 contours found on here
um and that's that's actually uh turns
this starts turning this into a math on
which one did we feed it uh we fed it
the
candy up here so we start to look at
these different setups get this out of
the way where's candy there's candy in
the back
and you can see that this drew 74
different uh like line connections on
here so now we're starting to actually
turn this into almost a mathematical
formula on this
and when we're looking at these we'll go
ahead and do draw contours
and here's our contour let's return the
concrete up here
we're going to put this on the blank
remember how we did the blank earlier uh
so we're actually going to take the
blank as remember i told you to use it
like a um a base that set up on there
and we can now redraw contours but in
this case we change the color uh so now
we're drawing the contours in red so
that's just kind of a fun thing you can
do on there to change the uh literally
change the appearance of the setup on
there
and let's go of course clean up our
setup and destroy all our windows and
move on to the next section and we're
going to look at color spaces
and let's start with
in the color spaces we're going to read
an image in i'm going to go ahead and
show the image part and just run that
i'm just going to put a
weight key in there a lot of times the
way key just helps because i'm pushing
all these graphics out through a single
kernel because i'm working in jupyter
notebook and things get hung up and so
waiting that extra 60 milliseconds can
sometimes really help sometimes just
flashing these pictures up and down
you'll see the response and other things
come up that really just pushing so much
out there
now one of the interesting things on
this is we imported matplot library and
so matplot library can now easily be
integrated with um
our
imagery and you can see all i did was
dump the image into the matplot library
and now i have the image here shown on
my matplot library setup one of the
things you're going to notice on this is
the colors all look off well again you
see that and you see that they're
supposed to be the same thing and you
should jump and say oh uh one of these
is rbg now there's gbr or bgr or
something like that and so it's reading
the the
reading the colors in a different order
that's all that means and you have to do
a transformation at some point to fix
that
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
uh we'll go back and gray scale it again
i'm gonna take our image of the park
um we'll put it into gray run there we
go
and in here we can convert our colors
we're just talking about uh we can
convert the color scheme i'm to run this
and you can see here we swapped the
scheme out and then i'm curious because
we did
up here plot it what does this look like
when we plot this new color down here
this new scheme what does that look like
on our setup
just go down there we go
and we call this hsv
so go down here instead of image i'm
going to plot
hsv and let's run that
and still way off on color schemes
you can see we've really messed up with
this hsv is another type of color scheme
i was curious because i did not think it
would come up correctly but i want to
see if it would
and we can also do a conversion to
what's called there we go
bgr blue green red to
lab and lab is just another color scheme
on here um and so you can see we
swatched the color screen it has some
really cool effects as far as what it
looks like in their view uh lab ranges
from it's kind of luminosity and then it
has like uh then the channels coming in
so it's a little bit different setup on
this but really you have to just play
with these to see what they look like we
talk about all these different color
schemes and all these switches on here
now the one that we were talking about
earlier
i mentioned was the bgr to rgb because
we use the bgr we'll just run this and
we see the color change on that
and then we'll go back up because i'm
still curious
um
okay there we go copy if this is the
same that matplot library uses and we'll
just type in rgb down here because
that's what we call their figure
and we'll run this and it will display
it oops it comes up and gives us a
problem because capitalization whoops
rgb there we go so let's go ahead and
run that
and that looks pretty close to the
original uh so this is when we're
converting between matplot library and
from the opencv we really want the blue
green red to red green blue that's the
conversion you want to use to get the
original picture on
there then we can also convert from
hsv to the lab like i said these
conversions
you have to look them up most of the
time but it's important to start
recognizing them so the very fact that
you're in here looking at this we're
talking about blue green red versus lab
versus the
where was it h
hsv setup on there
when you're dealing with pictures that
come in all varieties and so really
being able to switch between them is
important on here
so let's go ahead and take that
particular setup conversions and we'll
go ahead and clean up our palette
hopefully that will save us some
problems down the road
and we're going to start looking at the
color channels
uh and with this we'll go ahead and
reload the park back up we'll display
that just to ignore what the original
picture looked like
and then
for right now let's go ahead and take a
blank screen
and create ourselves a blank zeros
basically same shape as our park image
d type
u integer eight
don't really use it as a default anyway
so you don't really need to put that in
there but it's good to have and this is
an interesting
line here that opencv allows you to do a
cd split image and this basically just
takes the three channels in your numpy
image and you can use the numpy code and
figure it out i'm sure and splits it
into blue channel green channel and red
channel
and what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and
there we go
we're going to do a cv merge blue green
and red
and what we're doing is we're merging
the
blank one as far as blue the blank green
blank uh blank blank red so these are
the new channels as we combine them
that's what this merge thing does this
is kind of fun because you could have
merged you could take like your cat with
just the red whiskers merge that with
something
and then kind of mess with the images
just as far as like
you